so und damit kommen wir jetzt zum
nächsten Einzelplan Einzelplan 17 der
Bundesfamilienministerin Elisa Paus sie
soll im kommenden Jahr Ausgaben in Höhe
von 13,57 Milliarden Euro
vornehmen können das ist etwas mehr als
im Jahr davor 2022 waren es
12,39 das wird auch nötig sein dass es
ist dort höhere Ausgaben gibt allein
wenn man sich das Thema Kitas anschaut
im kommenden Jahr gibt es etliche
Kita-Plätze die fehlen
383.600 Kitaplätze fehlen so sagen ist
Berechnungen voraus besonders in
Westdeutschland übrigens gibt es
deutlich mehr Kinder die eigentlich in
einem Kindergarten gehen wollen aber für
die ist keinen Platz gibt und dazu kann
uns Paul Lehrer etwas dann Mitglied der
Kinderkommission des Deutschen
Bundestages
sind zusätzlich 45,6 Milliarden Schulden
damit insgesamt 500 Milliarden Euro neue
Schulden innerhalb eines Jahres das ist
eine besorgniserregend hohe Summe liebe
Kollegen Kollegen gleichzeitig werden in
dreistelliger Milliardenhöhe und
Umgehung der Schuldenbremse Gelder in
Sondervermögen geparkt
haushalterisch ist dies gerade vor dem
Hintergrund des aktuell vorliegenden
Klima krisenmixes ein ziemlicher Spagat
und eine enorme Belastung für unsere
kommende Generation die diese
Schuldenberge eines Tages abzahlen
müssen nicht umsonst heißt es die
Schulden von heute sind die Steuern von
Marken jeder Mensch jeder private
Haushalt bemüht sich zu sparen gerade in
der jetzigen Zeit aber bei der
ampelregierung findet sich nicht der
Spur
nicht der Hauch eines Spur von
Ausgabendisziplin oder gar notwendiger
Prioritätensetzung so etwas würde es mit
der Union niemals geben
und bei allen spürbaren Differenzen auch
innerhalb der Koalition ein Momentum
einziehen und genau das sehen wir leider
auch in Einzelplan 17 bereits im
Regierungsentwurf gab es einen aufwuchs
von 800 Millionen Euro gegenüber dem bis
dahin geltenden Finanzplan nach der
Bereinigungssitzung vor knapp zwei
Wochen kamen nochmal 690 Millionen dazu
damit vergrößert sich der Etat auf fast
13,6 Milliarden Euro das bedeutet eine
enorm Anstieg bei den gesetzlichen
Leistungen die mittlerweile über 90% des
etas ausmachen gerade Familienpolitik
sollte doch aber eigentlich mehr sein
als das bloße auszahlen von
Transferleistungen neben den über 90
Prozent gesetzlich gebundene Leistungen
die ausgebaut wurden singende
programmausgaben sowohl absolut als auch
relativ das merkt man vor allem bei den
Förderung in der Kinder- und
Jugendpolitik ein Minus von 30 Prozent
der qualifizierungsoffiziere als sie
ihrem karlschlag bzw der Mogelpackung
die sie jetzt bei den sprachkitas oder
bei Kindertagespflege Vorhaben
liebe Frau Ministerin in den letzten
Wochen waren immer wir zusammen
getroffen sind war das Thema natürlich
sprach Kitas unumgänglich noch in der
ersten Lesung dieses Haushaltes Brote
ein Ende dieses Programms zum ersten
Januar 2023 das haben sie jetzt eben
schon hier bis zum ersten Juli
hinausgeschoben aber Fakt ist auch die
109 Millionen die im Haushalt für die
Sprache das verankert sind nehmen sie
doch linke Tasche rechte Tasche wieder
aus dem guten Kita-Gesetz von den 2
Milliarden die im guten kindergesetz
stehen kommen 109 Millionen quasi in die
sprach Kitas und das bis zum Sommer zu
reden wohl wissend das nicht alle Länder
bisher mitmachen Frau Ministerin glaube
ich auch ehrlich machen ein tolles
Programm ein Programm das wir in der
großen Koalition eben seit 11 Jahren mit
großer Leidenschaft vorangebracht haben
nach mir reden wenn Sie wollen was wir
große Leidenschaft vorangebracht haben
dass dem Thron ein Ende und immerhin
über 7000 sprachkleider in Deutschland
wissen nicht wie es am ersten Juli
weitergeht wir haben einen Moderatorin
sechs Monate aber am ersten Juli werden
der Bundesländer noch nicht Klarheit
haben wie sie mit ihren beschäftigtenden
sprachgebieters umgehen und das haben
die Kinder in Deutschland nicht verdient
in der ersten Lesung habe ich hier den
Kollegen tschirski getroffen ist hat
leider nicht da die Fachkräfte
Problematik in zehn zwölf Jahren legen
wir heute zugrunde wenn wir Kinder dies
an sich geistig drauf hätten oder
intellektuell drauf hätten in der
sprachlichen Förderung nicht rechtzeitig
an die Hand nehmen und ihnen helfen und
ja meine Vorstellung war
175/50 das heißt nächstes Jahr
übernehmen wir die 200 Millionen für die
Sprache die das als Bund noch mal und
dann gehen wir auf 75 runter und dann 50
50 wird teilen uns ein Stück weit die
Aufgaben diese sprachlichen Förderung im
Kinderbereich halte ich für gut da haben
sie gehabt
haben sie ausgeführt dafür braucht man
eine grundbesitzänderung wir haben
gerade eben im Plenum den Haushalt der
Einzelplan 25
wohnständebauförderung diskutiert wir
haben 790 Millionen Heu in der Stelle
bei Förderung ein Superprogramm der von
dem viele Kommunen profitieren wo Bund
und Land zusammenarbeiten was ja bei der
historischen Bausubstanz im Gemeinden
den Städten eben hinbekommen sollten wir
bei den kleinen Kindern auch hinbekommen
Frau Ministerin ich glaube das wäre ganz
wichtig dass man diese Sache noch mal
angucken bevor dieses Programm eben
entsprechend hier komplett kaputt geht
deshalb mal Appell noch mal an sie
schauen Sie sich das noch mal an wie
schauen wir mit den sprachkitas nach dem
ersten Julia aus das ist die
Hauptaufgabe das ist die Achillesferse
des Einzelplan 177 in diesem
Bundeshaushalt
Frau Ministerin sie haben noch ein paar
Tage Zeit am 27 am kommenden Freitag
wird der Haushalt verabschiedet insofern
eben wir sind zu Gesprächen offen ich
hoffe dass es uns gelingt dieses gute
Programm das wir gemeinsam über
Jahrzehnte wird elf Jahre eben hier
vorangebracht haben das dieses Programm
zu retten die Kinder in Deutschland
haben es verdient es verdient in schwarz
alle edlen und gerechten sind und die
Sprache das noch mal genau zu bemühen
bevor wir da im Sommer ihre massiv
bescheiden anrichten herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
sie wollen jetzt nicht wegen der 8
Sekunden besonders gelobt werden die sie
eingesperrt werden
nächster Redner ist der Kollege Bruno
Hödl Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das waren
wirklich sehr herausfordernde
Haushaltsberatungen unter dem Eindruck
von Putins Krieg in der Ukraine und
dessen Konsequenzen natürlich auch hier
bei uns vor allem wirtschaftlicher und
sozialer Natur viele Familien leiden
unter den hohen Preisen deswegen
mobilisieren wir sehr viel Geld für
Entlastungsmaßnahmen das zeigt sich auch
Inventar des Ministeriums für Familie
Senioren Frauen und Jugend der im
parlamentarischen Verfahren jetzt noch
mal um 689 Millionen Euro auf über 13,5
Milliarden anwächst wir erhöhen den
Mindestunterhalt den Kinderzuschlag und
das Kindergeld deutlich auf einheitlich
250 € unabhängig ob erstes drittes oder
viertes Kind das ist schlichtweg
notwendig um die Familien von den hohen
Preisen zu entlasten und wir senden
damit eben auch ein deutliches Signal an
die Familien dass wir sie im Blick haben
aber vor allem auch dass wir konsequent
handeln liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Kampf gegen
Kinderarmut hat für uns absolute
Priorität und da will ich schon auch
noch mal sagen dass natürlich es auch
wichtig ist dass wir die Eltern
existenziell absichern wenn wir die
Kinder aus der Armut holen wollen und
daher ist es gut dass beim Bürgergeld
jetzt eine Einigung in Sicht ist und
doch muss ich in Richtung der Union
sagen dass sie mit ihrer Kampagne gegen
das Bürgergeld wirklichen bedenkliches
Menschenbild offenbart haben immer
wieder haben sie mit ihren Äußerungen
Betroffene alle in einen Sack gepackt
und dann das Label zu faul zum Arbeiten
drauf gedrückt ohne die Hintergründe die
Situation der Menschen wirklich zu
erkennen das ist eine Politik der
sozialen Kälte liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir als Ampelkoalition haben da
einen anderen Ansatz echte
Existenzsicherung
Hinzuverdienstmöglichkeiten weiter
Bildungsoffensive gerade auch um junge
Menschen in Ausbildung und Arbeit
nachhaltig zu vermitteln es geht um
Respekt vor der Lebensleistung eines
jeden Menschen um Respekt geht es liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wir legen in diesem Haushalt eben
auch ein sehr sehr starken Schwerpunkt
auf den Schutz von Kindern und da müssen
wir über das große Problem
sexualisierter Gewalt gegen Kinder
sprechen ExpertInnen gehen von ein bis
zwei betroffenen Kindern pro Schulklasse
aus daher ist es richtig dass wir die
Sensibilisierungskampagne der
Unabhängigen Beauftragten jetzt wirklich
aus finanzieren mit fünf Millionen Euro
wenn Erwachsene Missbrauch besser
erkennen können dann können wir Kinder
auch besser schützen deswegen ist das
eine wichtige Maßnahme überfälliger
Schritt im Sinne der Kinder
es ist auch gut es ist auch gut dass wir
jetzt für die sprachkitas eine
Übergangslösung finden konnten 109
Millionen Euro stehen im Haushalt bereit
um den Übergang an die Länder bis das
kita-qualitätsgesetz greift zu
überbrücken in meinem Wahlkreis in
Lübeck werden wir davon profitieren dass
die Ministerin aminata Turin eigenes
Sprachförderprogramm in
Schleswig-Holstein auflegt und
beispielsweise in Bayern würde genauso
davon profitiert werden wenn Markus
Söder sich ein Beispiel an
Schleswig-Holstein nehme und anstatt
immer nur Verantwortung auf den Bund
abzuschieben endlich selbst in die
Sprachförderung in den Kitas investiert
das wäre der richtige Weg liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ein weiterer
Schwerpunkt ein weiterer Schwerpunkt der
Beratung war die niedrigschwellige
Förderung und Prävention im Bereich der
psychischen Gesundheit von Kindern und
Jugendlichen viele Studien belegen ja
dass unter dem Eindruck der
corona-pandemie die Fallzahlen bei
Depression
bei Angst und Essstörungen aber auch bei
suizidalen Verhalten von Jugendlichen
deutlich zugenommen haben das ist ein
großes Problem dem wir uns widmen müssen
und genau das machen wir auch mit diesem
Haushalt in dem wir zusätzlich 33
Millionen Euro einsetzen um
niedrigschwellige und leicht erreichbare
Hilfsangebote auszubauen und auch die
psychosozialen Zentren stärken wir in
ihrer wichtigen Arbeit die Jugend
migrationsdienste stocken wir auf wir
setzen Haushaltsmittel ein für eine
starke kritische Zivilgesellschaft denn
sie ist der Grundpfeiler unserer
lebendigen Demokratie und auch deswegen
ist dieser Haushalten guter Haushalt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und beim Kampf gegen Diskriminierung
gehen wir wirklich voran und stoppen die
Mittel der Antidiskriminierungsstelle um
8 Millionen Euro auf es gibt die ADS
seit 2006 die wurde allerdings von den
Vorgängerregierungen nie bedarfsgerecht
ausgestattet war also im Grunde ein
zahnloser Tiger wir ändern das jetzt es
ist unser verfassungsmäßiger Auftrag
gegen Diskriminierung zu kämpfen die
Menschenwürde bedingungslos zu schützen
und es brauchte eben eine ampelregierung
um diesen Verfassungsauftrag endlich
nachzukommen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zum Abschluss zusammenfassen
mit diesem reagieren wir
verantwortungsvoll in diesen
Krisenzeiten machen aber eben nicht nur
reaktive Politik sondern richten den
Blick schon auch nach vorne das ist der
Kern progressiver und zukunftsgewandter
Politik und der Haushalt liefert genau
dafür eine gute Grundlage herzlichen
Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
war
das Grünen
und Ulrike Schielke Ziesing
Berichterstatterin für diesen Einzelplan
im Haushaltsausschuss
wir stehen am Beginn einer Rezession
während über Sparmaßnahmen gesprochen
wird die Bevölkerung zum Sparen
aufgerufen wird und mit Millionen von
Familien am Rand der Verzweiflung sind
wird Geld für unnötige Prestigeprojekte
ausgegeben werden lobby-vereine bedacht
und wird am falschen Ende gespart der
Haushalt des Familienministeriums ist
dafür exemplarisch er setzt die falschen
Prioritäten und ist von grüner Ideologie
gerade zu durchdrängt zu den falschen
Prioritäten ist das Programm sprach
Kitas das beste Beispiel Kostenfaktor
etwa 250 Millionen Euro pro Jahr dieses
Kita dieses Programm ist die Lebensader
viele Kitas über 7.000 Fachkräfte werden
damit bundesweit finanziert und die
sprachliche Entwicklung der Kinder zu
fördern wie wichtig das ist zeigen uns
die jüngsten Studien wonach die
frühkindliche Sprachbildung dank der
corona-maßnahmen ins Bodenlose viel und
was machen sie als nahezu erster
Anzahlung im Familienministerium wurde
dieses Programm gestrichen nach einer
großen Protestwelle ruderte das
Ministerium nun zurück stellte für den
Übergang also bis Juli juni 2023 doch
noch einmal 109 Euro 109 Millionen Euro
zur Verfügung Gelder die übrigens mit
einem Sperrvermerk versehen wurden groß
angekündigt wurden zwei Milliarden Euro
aus dem neuen gute Kita-Gesetz das jetzt
kita-qualitätsgesetz heißt das ist aber
eine gewaltige Nebelkerze es ist genau 0
Cent mehr als bis dato ohnehin durch das
Gute Kita-Gesetz geflossen sind wo sie
mal wieder völlig ins transparent kürzen
ist beispielsweise bei den
Investitionsprogramm für die
kinderbetreuungsfinanzierung in den
Jahren 20 und 21 war dort immerhin eine
Milliarde Euro vorgesehen würde man also
eine Bilanzsumme bei der kita-förderung
vornehmen würde die Rechnung
folgendermaßen aussehen minus 250
Millionen bei den Bundesprogrammen
inklusiver der sprach Kitas
minus 500 Millionen pro Jahr bei den
Investitionsprogrammen das macht für
2023 dann ein Minus von 750 Millionen
Euro die bundesweit wegfallen das ist
unfassbar für eine Familienminister
aber sie setzen eben ihre Prioritäten
anders denn es muss ja Geld her für ihre
lobby-kollegen und die grüne Ideologie
Agenda ihres Ministeriums für die
sogenannten Maßnahmen zur Stärkung von
Vielfalt und Toleranz sind wieder 200
Millionen vorgesehen dabei das dabei
auch Organisationen mit direkter
Verbindung in die Muslimbrüderschaft
gefördert werden egal und auch bei ihren
lobby-kollegen gibt es einen Geld Segen
am besten sieht man das bei der
antidiskriminierungsbeauftragten Frau
Ackermann ihr Amt völlig losgelöst von
jeder Verantwortung bekommt im nächsten
Jahr
13,4 Millionen Euro das sind satte 250%
mehr als noch 2021 um das Geld dafür
aufzutreiben wurde übrigens bei den
Frauenhäusern gekürzt
wenn ich deine Liste weiterführen darf
es geht wieder zehn Millionen Euro für
die respektcoaches 4,2 Millionen für die
Jugendorganisationen der politischen
Parteien im Klartext ein Geschenk der
Steuerzahler an die politischen Jugend
Organisationen von grüner Jugend Jusos
Linksjugend und Co 10 Millionen für
Wohlfahrtsverbände zur Beratung von
Flüchtlingen ich kann mir hier schon
vorstellen dass diese demnächst den
Antrag aufs Bürger gleich Bürgergeld
gleich mitgeben bei der Beratung und und
und und die Krönung des Ganzen waren
aber auch ernsthaft die Anträge der
Koalition in der Bereinigungssitzung vor
zwei Wochen ohne Scham haben sie
tatsächlich Gelder explizit an bestimmte
Firmen vergeben da werden die jährliche
Zahlungen an die fineo GAG von 350.000
Euro oder die 1,3 Millionen für
lgbtq-projekte das meiste davon 850.000
€ explizit für pink dort normalerweise
werden für den Haushalt eines
Ministeriums Aufgaben und Ziele
definiert dann Gelder zur Verfügung
gestellt und anschließend Aufträge
ausgeschrieben auf die die Firmen sich
dann bewerben können aber sowas ist
natürlich sehr lästig und aufwendig das
ist doch viel bequemer gleich eine
konkrete Firma zu benennen und in den
Haushalt zu schreiben da spart man sich
die Grenze Bürokratie es geht ja nur um
läppische 1,2 Millionen Euro wer soll
sich denn schon daran stören das ist
Vetternwirtschaft par excellence
während die Bevölkerung zum Sparen
aufgerufen wird werden Schulden gemacht
werden als gäbe es kein Morgen werden
hier ohne Scham Gelder ein lobbyver eine
verteilt das ist dreist und es ist mir
unbegreiflich warum die FDP diesen
ganzen Irrsinn mitmacht wir von der AFD
werden jedenfalls diesen Einzelplan in
diesen Haushalt nicht mittragen nicht so
lange Ideologie und Lobbyismus über die
Bedürfnisse der Familien in diesem Land
gestellt werden vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin
Elisabeth Kaiser SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Bürgerinnen und bürgerwerte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen letzte Woche da war ich in
meinen Wahlkreis in caaschwitz in der
Kita zur märchenbude zu Gast und dort
habe ich den Kindern ein Buch vorgelesen
die neugierige kleine Hexe und bei
solchen besuchen das spüre ich immer wie
wichtig Fantasie freie Entfaltung und
Zusammenhalt für den Alltag und es
heranwachsen unserer Kinder sind die
Erzieherinnen und Erzieherinnen
Kindergärten tun tagtäglich alles dafür
dass unsere Kinder in diesem frühen
Lebensabschnitt mit einer positiven und
selbstbewussten Einstellung zum Leben
aufwachsen aber auch schon
verantwortungsvollen Umgang mit anderen
kennenlernen und dafür möchte ich allen
Erzieherinnen erzählen von Herzen danken
für mich als BürgerInnen und aber auch
Mutter einer fast zweijährigen Tochter
ist das Ansporn in Anspruch zugleich für
die Rahmenbedingungen zu sorgen um die
es für eine gute Entwicklung unserer
Kinder braucht in meiner Fraktionen auch
in der Koalition errichten wir unseren
Fokus und um politischen Handeln
besonders auf diejenigen der meisten
Unterstützung benötigen wir lassen die
Menschen Alt und Jung mit ihren Sorgen
nicht allein wir arbeiten aktuell mit
Hochdruck daran dass alle die steigenden
Lebenshaltungskosten insbesondere für
Strom und Gas bewältigen können neben
kurzfristigen Entlastungen gilt es
soziale Gerechtigkeit über grundlegende
Sozialreformen wie eben den Wohngeld den
Bürgergeld und der Kindergrundsicherung
dauerhaft sicher zu stellen in den
parlamentarischen Beratungen für den
Etat des
Bundesministeriums für Familien Senioren
Frauen und Jugend haben sie den
Regierungsentwurf an einigen Stellen
noch verbessern können und finanziell
gestärkt der etwa wächst und das in
diesen herausfordernden Zeiten und
obwohl die cor Programme Auslaufen an
dieser Stelle möchte ich auch der
Ministerin ihrem Haus aber auch meinen
lieben mich mit Berichterstattern Bruno
Höhne und Claudia rassifischen für die
Zusammenarbeit danken
über 13,5 Milliarden Euro investieren
wir im kommenden Jahr in Leistungen und
Programme für Kinder Jugendliche
Familien ältere und viele Ehrenamtliche
in unserem Land besonders freue ich mich
dass es gelungen ist eine
Übergangslösung für die sprachkitas zu
finden und damit verschaffen wir den
Ländern mehr Zeit das Programm in
eigener Verantwortung zu übernehmen und
wichtig war uns in den Beratungen auch
mehr für den Schutz von Kindern zu tun
damit weniger Kindern in den ersten
Lebensjahren Vernachlässigung und Gewalt
in ihrem privaten Umfeld erfahren aber
auch Familien in schwierigen
Lebenssituationen und Lebenslagen
Unterstützung finden haben wir die
Mittel für die Stiftung früher Höfen
Hilfen erhöht und weil der Schutz von
Kindern und Jugendlichen so wichtig ist
und oberste Priorität haben muss stärken
wir auch die aufklärungs- und
Sensibilisierungskampagne der
Unabhängigen Beauftragten für Fragen des
sexuellen Kindern Missbrauchs
als Koalition da ist uns bewusst dass
die Jahre der Pandemie Kinder und
Jugendliche besonders stark belastet
haben und deshalb halten wir was wir im
Koalitionsvertrag versprochen haben das
zukunftspaket für Bewegung Kultur und
Gesundheit soll Kindern und Jugendliche
in ihrer ganzheitlichen Entwicklung
fördern und das Paket konnten wir in den
Haushaltsberatungen im weiteren Mittel
auf insgesamt 55 Millionen Euro erhöhen
und damit leben wir auch einen
Grundstein für ein neues Modellprogramm
die mental health Coaches kommen
bundesweit an Schulen zum Einsatz und
kümmern sich um psychisch und sozial
belastete junge Menschen und das sind in
diesen Zeiten leider nicht weniger die
Jungs veröffentliche Studie Jugend in
Deutschland zeigt dass wir weiter daran
arbeiten müssen die Bedürfnisse und
Interessen von Jugendlichen zu hören und
zu berücksichtigen und genau das haben
wir uns als Ampel vorgenommen in den
Haushaltsverhandlungen haben wir die
Kinder und jugendplan des Bundes weiter
gestärkt für die Arbeit der
Jugendverbände konnten wir die Erhöhung
aus 2022 auch für das 2523 erreichen und
damit wirksame Jugendarbeit absichern
Jugendverbände die sinnvolle
Freizeitangebote bieten ermöglichen es
Jugendlichen wichtige Erfahrung der
Selbstwirksamkeit zu machen und sich
auch in Verantwortung für andere zu üben
und als Mitglied der Naturfreundin Gera
weiß ich dass es sehr sinnvoll
investiert das Geld
wir machen damit junge Menschen stark
und weil wir alle Kinder und Jugendliche
in unserem Land in den Blick nehmen
stärken wir auch die Arbeit der
Jugendmigrationsdienste damit ihren
Beratungs Bildungs- und
Freizeitangeboten begleiten sie junge
Menschen mit Migrationsgeschichte weil
Übergang von der Schule bis ins
Berufsleben und im engen Zusammenhang zu
den Jugendmigrationsdienste stehen auch
die Respekt Coaches ich bin persönlich
sehr froh dass wir Ihre Arbeit mit
zusätzlichen 10 Millionen Euro absichern
konnten und in meiner Heimatstadt Gera
da habe ich mir selbst ein Bild davon
machen können wie wichtig diese Form der
Sozialen Arbeit an Schulen ist nun
wissen wir aber
dass Menschen
dass Menschen die aus ihrer Heimat vor
Krieg und Verfolgung fliehen müssen
vielfach traumatisierende Erlebnisse
durchleben mussten und damit dürfen wir
sie hier nicht alleine lassen deshalb
ist es gut wenn wir mehr Mittel für
bundesweite Koordinierung der
psychosozialen Beratung für geflüchtete
und Folteropfer zur Verfügung stellen
liebe Kolleginnen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen gerade in
Krisenzeiten ist es notwendig
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt zu
stärken und das bildet auch das
Bundesministeriums Familie Senioren
Frauen und Jugendamt die unterstützen
Familien mit Kindern und haben die
gesetzlichen Leistungen die Kindergeld
Kinderzuschlag und Unterhaltsvorschuss
noch einmal spürbar erfüllt bei der
Projektförderung setzen wir zusätzlichen
Mitteln wichtige Akzente im Bereich der
Früh Prävention der Integration sowie
der Demokratie und engagementförderung
darauf werden die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meiner Fraktion noch eingehen
aber darüber hinaus arbeiten wir auch
weiter als Koalition intensiv daran dass
weniger Kindern Armut leben müssen jedes
Kind die gleichen staatsschancen hat und
wir auch künftig in einer freien offenen
und vielfältigen Gesellschaft leben
können vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
mit Kaiser die Berichterstatterin der
SPD-Fraktion für diesen Einzelplan 17
ist folgt die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende und
haushaltspolitische Sprecherin der
Linksfraktion gesehene lutsch
die Bundesregierung feiert sich selbst
für die geplante Kindergelderhöhung
die Hälfte der Menschen die ihre
Lebensmittel bei der Tafel holen müssen
sind Alleinerziehende und Kinder das ist
doch ein Armutszeugnis für unser Land
ein Armutszeugnis für diese Regierung
das muss ich ändern meine Damen und
Herren
das ist ja nicht nur ungerecht und
beschneidet die Chancen dieser Kinder es
wird auch viel Potenzial verschleudert
es ist wissenschaftlich erwiesen das
gerechte Gesellschaften für allerbester
sind halten wir uns daran meine Damen
und Herren die Bertelsmann-Stiftung
zeigt in einer aktuellen Studie das
Risiko in Armut zu rutschen ist für
Paaren mit mindesten
s da so hoch wie für Familien mit zwei
Kindern und 43 Prozent eine unfassbare
Zahl
43% der Alleinerziehenden gelten als
einkommensarm das dürfen wir nicht
länger hinnehmen
wolfgang Büscher Sprecher des Berliner
Kinder- und jugendnetzwerks Arche sagt
aufgrund der massiv steigenden Preise
können es schon im nächsten Jahr zu
katastrophalen Zuständen für Kinder
kommen seine Prognose Anfang nächsten
Jahres werden die ersten Menschen
hungern das müssen wir gemeinsam
verändern meine Damen und Herren
die Bundesregierung
ist informiert darum muss der Kampf
gegen die Kinderarmut endlich
entschlossen aufgenommen werden wir
linken unterstützen die
Kindergrundsicherung aber sie kommt zu
spät 20 25 ist zu spät es muss schneller
gehandelt werden
die Begründung das ist so lange dauere
weil so viele Ministerien daran arbeiten
das zeigt doch nur dass die
Bundesregierung die falschen Prioritäten
setzt
wie schnell konnte die Bundesregierung
die Ampel plus Union plus Teile der AFD
das 100 Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen
für die Bundeswehr beschließen von der
Idee bis zur Beschlussfassung hat das
gerade 100 Tage gedauert ich finde die
Grundsicherung für Kinder die muss so
schnell wie möglich auf den Weg da gibt
es kein Vertun
jetzt hat die afdp auch noch die
aktienrente über Nacht aus dem Boden
gestampft die aktienrente Macht die
Fondsmanager reich aber nicht die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner das ist der
falsche Weg meine Damen und Herren es
geht aber nicht nur um die
Kindergrundsicherung es geht auch um
Kitas Schulen säuglingsstationen
Krankenhäusern und Wohnungen für
Familien mit Kindern
alle Kinder brauchen wird von dieser
Bundesregierung ausgebremst das darf
nicht länger so sein meine Damen und
Herren ja ich weiß Bund und Länder
müssen wirksam und verlässlich
zusammenarbeiten aber wechselseitige
Schuldzuweisung helfen kein Kind Carmen
Kindern erst recht nicht und
abschließend die Schuldenbremse ist eine
zukunftsbremse insbesondere für Kinder
und Enkelkinder sie ist ökonomischer
Unsinn sie muss weg vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin
Claudia gaffelhüchen FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
der Etat des Familienministeriums lag
schon im Regierungsentwurf 280 Millionen
Euro über dem Soll 2022 und er wurde nun
im Laufe des parlamentarischen
Verfahrens auf knapp 13,6 Milliarden
aufgestockt
das ist in jedem Fall eine gute
Nachricht vor allem für viele Familien
die von erhöhten gesetzlichen Leistungen
profitieren zum Beispiel vom
Kinderzuschlag oder den Zahlungen aus
dem Unterhaltsvorschussgesetz es
bedeutet aber auch dass erschreckend
viele Menschen auf Hilfe angewiesen sind
und dass die Zahl im Zuge von Corona
lockdowns und
ukraine-bremst zu wachsen scheint gerade
im Bereich der psychosozialen Hilfe sind
die Bedarfe immens und zwar für deutsche
Kinder und Familien als auch seit
Februar diesen Jahres für die vielen
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine
ich freue mich daher sehr dass wir in
dieser letzten haushaltsrunde nochmals
die Gelder für die frühen Hilfe Hilfen
um fünf Millionen aufstocken konnten und
die psychosoziale Versorgung
geflüchteter sogar um 9,7 Millionen
ich selber aber kürzlich als
delegationsleiterin einer Reise des
Einzelplans 23 in Moldau und der
Ukrainer und bin von den Eindrücken dort
immer noch nachhaltig beeindruckt ich
weiß jetzt aus eigener Anschauung dass
unsere Hilfen vor Ort dringend gebraucht
werden und ich weiß dass das für unsere
Unterstützung der Flüchtlinge hier im
Land gerade auch im Einzelplan 17 ganz
genauso geht
was mich ganz besonders in Moldau
wirklich beeindruckt hat obwohl die
Aufgabe für dieses kleine Land hier
unglaublich sind
500.000 ukrainische Flüchtlinge kam in
ein Land mit knapp 4 Millionen
Einwohnern werden diese Aufgaben dort
ohne Gejammer und Klagen angepackt und
zwar schnell pragmatisch und sehr
effizient jeder tut was er kann und
niemand versucht erst einmal zu klären
ob vielleicht jemand anderes zuständig
ist und so ein bisschen mehr von diesem
zupackenden Wesen würde ich mir seitdem
in Deutschland wünschen wenn ich auf die
Länder schaue
der in Haushaltsdebatten mit chronischer
Abwesenheit glänzen
denn die Länder haben
inzwischen deutlich weniger pro
kopfschulden und höhere Einnahmen als
der Bund bekommen aber massive
Unterstützung in vielen Bereichen die
ganz klar länderaufgabe sind und dennoch
hört man natürlich nie ein Dankeschön im
Gegenteil die Forderungen an dem Bund
werden immer mehr immer dreister und der
Tonfall immer hysterische
ich muss schon sagen die Debatte um die
sprachkitas und das Gerangel um eine
übergangsfinanzierung bis zum Sommer war
für mich der traurige Höhepunkt in
dieser seltsamen Haltung der Länder
gegenüber dem Bund und insbesondere
gegenüber den haushälteren und
Haushälter und das um das ganz klar zu
sagen
der gibt es hier niemanden der nicht für
die sprachkitas wäre wir alle sehen in
frühkindlicher Bildung und Teilhabe
einen der wichtigsten Bausteine für eine
gelingende Integration gerade deshalb
hätte ich aber neben einer besseren und
früheren Kommunikation seitens des
Ministeriums vor allem von den Ländern
wesentlich mehr Eigeninitiative erwartet
gerne Weise ich noch mal darauf hin hier
würde ich mir neben den Grundsätzen der
haushaltswahrheit und Klarheit auch in
Zukunft mehr Haushalts wünschen
die Länder
die Länder haben es nun in der Hand
diese Bundesgelder schnell und
zielgerichtet einzusetzen und das
kita-qualitätsgesetz zu einem Erfolg zu
machen wie wichtig ihnen die Zukunft der
Kinder in ihrem Land jeweils ist wird
man jetzt sehr schön daran ablesen
können ob nur das Minimum von 50% in
Qualität gesteckt wird oder ob ein Land
nahezu 100% ermittel in wirkliche
Verbesserungen investiert darunter auch
gerne in das zukunftsweisende Thema der
Sprache Kitas
und jetzt noch ein letzter Punkt in
Sachen Kinder und Zukunft neben all den
Geldern die wir im Einzelplan 17 und
anderswo verteilen und umschichten
können ist das Wichtigste dass wir
endlich wieder die Schuldenbremse
einhalten damit beweisen wir als
Parlamentarier unseren Respekt vor dem
Grundgesetz damit handeln wir als
haushälteren und Haushältern
verantwortungsvoll und nachhaltig und
damit leisten wir als Eltern und
Politiker dem wichtigsten Beitrag zur
Generation Gerechtigkeit nämlich unseren
Kindern und Enkeln etwas Besseres zu
vererben als Schulden vielen Dank
zum Schluss und noch mal der Hinweis auf
die Schuldenbremse eines doch der Themen
die besonders von der FDP immer wieder
angesprochen werden im Parlament aber
natürlich auch in der
Regierung und Silvia breja spricht in
nun für die Unionsfraktion sich die
Sprecherin für Familie Senioren Frauen
und Jugend
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Frau Ministerin Paul schade ich
hätte gerne auf Ihre Rede reagiert heute
drehen wir das mal um offensichtlich ja
es sind schwierige Zeiten in denen Sie
diesen Bundeshaushalt aufstellen und ja
Herr Kollege Hönel es gibt eine Menge
finanzielle Entlastungen für Familien
und Kindern in diesem Bundeshaushalt
insgesamt aber eben nicht im Einzelplan
17 und es passiert vor allen Dingen auch
der mehr aufwuchs sie haben schon gesagt
auf die gesetzlichen Ansprüche die
einfach bestehen und dazu gehört eben
auch das Kindergeld für dass sie sich ja
so gerne feiern aber am Ende ist es nur
wenig eine Entscheidung hier im Haus es
ist viel mehr eine Folge aus dem
existenzminimumsbericht auf dessen
Reaktion hin sie die steuerlichen
Freibeträge angepasst haben die dann
immer die dann gekoppelt werden eben
auch an die Erhöhung des Kindergeldes
und ich finde es sehr gut und richtig
dass das Kindergeld erhöht wird was wir
allerdings
sehen ist die Wechsel in der Systematik
den Wechsel den Sie vornehmen dass sie
nämlich jetzt jedes Kind gleich fördern
und nicht mehr anerkennen dass mehr Kind
Familien eine besondere Belastung
zugestanden werden muss dass das dritte
und folgende Kind einfach mehr kostet
und diesen Wechsel sehen wir einfach
anders und vor allen Dingen reicht Geld
alleine an dieser Stelle einfach nicht
es muss doch unser aller Anspruch sein
und es ist zumindest laut ihrer ersten
Rede auch hier im Haus Frau Ministerin
ihr Anspruch Chancengleichheit
herzustellen für Kinder in diesem Land
egal wo und wie sie in diesem Land
geboren werden und in welcher Umgebung
hinein Realität in ihrem Haushalt sieht
allerdings leider anders aus und ja auch
wenn sie es nicht mehr hören können sie
beenden das Sprachprogramm das
Bundesprogramm der sprach Kitas sie
beenden ist zum 30.06 und jetzt rühmen
sie mit sich damit dass sie 109 Milli
Millionen doch noch bis Mitte Juni zur
Verfügung stellen und ich höre es in
ihren Reihen während der reden es ist
Ländersache es ist Ländersache ja ich
sehe das vom Grundsatz auch so hätten
sie es vorbereitet und nicht bis mitte
diesen Jahres so getan als wird das
Bundesprogramm fortgesetzt hätten es
Absprachen gegeben mit den Ländern hätte
es Vereinbarungen gegeben wie es
fortgesetzt wird und vor allen Dingen
wenn es jetzt für die Übergangsphase sie
sind ja zurückgerudert wirklich
zusätzliches Geld gewesen wäre das ist
es aber leider nicht es ist ein linke
Taschenrechner Tasche spielen indem sie
es bei den zwei Milliarden für für das
Gitter qualitätsgesetz gute Kita-Gesetz
wegnehmen und hier den sprachkita für
die sprach Kita sozusagen zweckgebunden
einsetzen wo allerdings sollen die
Länder denn Gelder wegnehmen wenn sie
gleichzeitig wie weiter die
Beitragsfreiheit möglich machen ich bin
gespannt in wessen Länder
Verantwortungen tatsächlich dieses
Programm am Ende fortgesetzt werden wird
und sie streichen ja nicht nur an dieser
Stelle im Bereich frühkindlicher Bildung
sie stellen die Fachkräfte Offensive ein
okay aber unser Antrag bezieht sich noch
auf ein weiteres Bundesprogramm nämlich
dass der Kindertagespflege zu dem bis
jetzt irgendwie noch niemand gemerkt hat
dass es wegfällt das ist nämlich
versteckt in einem Haushaltstitel
Maßnahmen zur Umsetzung der
Qualifizierungsoffensive es geht darum
die Weiterentwicklung des Systems der
Kindertagespflege und auch um die
pädagogische Arbeit der
Kindertagespflege Personen auch dieses
Bundesprogramm lassen sie auch Auslaufen
es endet und auch das übertragen sie in
die Verantwortung der Länder ohne
Absprache vielleicht auch in der
Hoffnung dass es keiner gemerkt hat und
sie haben es gerade schon angesprochen
Frau Kollegin mein persönliches
Herzensanliegen jedenfalls sind sie
Stiftung der Frühen Hilfen 51 Millionen
gab es jetzt haben sie 5 Millionen oben
drauf gepackt das reicht aber nicht
aktuell sind 86 Millionen im letzten
Jahr waren 60 million und für die
Stiftung frühe Hilfen gerade für die
niedrigschwelligen Angebote der Kinder
der werdenden Eltern und der Kinder bis
drei Jahren babylotsen ist ein Beispiel
die Familienhebammen sind da Beispiele
die kennt jeder von uns aus seinem
Wahlkreis gerade hier haben wir aber
Kostensteigerungen beim Personal und
auch bei den Sachkosten und wenn Sie
hier nur um 5 Millionen aufstocken dann
bedeutet das gleichzeitig ein
tatsächlicher Rückgang beim
Leistungsangebot obwohl der Bedarf nach
Corona und in dieser jetzigen
schwierigen Zeit einfach riesig ist und
deswegen auch hier unser Antrag Frau
Ministerin Paulus ihren Worten
Chancengleichheit zu erreichen lassen
Sie in diesem Haushalt jedenfalls leider
keine Taten folgen und ziehen sich in
weiten Teilen aus der Verantwortung
einfach zurück und überlassen es den
Ländern die müssen das dann schon
richten
Chancengleichheit ist aber unsere aller
Aufgabe hier im Haus genauso wie in den
Ländern und in Zusammenarbeit mit den
Kommunen denn es muss unser aller
Anspruch sein und sie kürzen an einer
Position ganz besonders bei denen
unserer Kinder im frühkindlichen Bereich
im Bereich der frühkindlichen Bildung
und da lassen Sie Frau Ministerin mit
diesem Haushalt die Kinder im Stich und
das finden wir sehr schade vielen dank
vielen Dank jede Fraktion hat jetzt
schon mal in dieser Debatte gesprochen
und so kann die
Bundesfamilienministerin dieser Pause
nun auch Antworten auf die verschiedenen
Aspekte die hier schon zu ihrem
Einzelplan genannt wurden
herr Präsident Schwerte Kolleginnen
dieses Land lässt sich nicht spalten mit
diesem Leitgedanken haben wir diese
Haushaltsberatung geführt dieses Land
hält nämlich zusammen Politik Wirtschaft
Zivilgesellschaft die Menschen alle
miteinander und in all ihrer Vielfalt
solidarisch meine Damen und Herren
und diese Koalition und diese Koalition
stellt sich der Wirklichkeit wie sie ist
wie reagieren schnell auf Inflation
aufgestiegene Energie und
Lebenshaltungskosten und wir haben eben
auch die im Blick die es besonders
brauchen mit dem ersten mit dem zweiten
und dem dritten Rettungspaket mit den
Kindern sofort zu schlagen mit der mit
der wohngeldreform mit dem 200
Milliarden Abwehr Schirm gegen die
gestiegenden Strom und Gaspreise wir
lassen keinen Zweifel daran wir sehen
die sorgen wir nehmen Ihre Sorgen ernst
und wir handeln danach meine Damen und
Herren ich bin überzeugt dass es nicht
nur gut um die Krise abzuwehren sondern
wir können alle gemeinsam dadurch auch
sehr viel gewinnen
[Applaus]
unterstützt Familien Senioren Frauen und
die junge Generation im Jahr 2023 mit
13,6 Milliarden Euro das wurde bereits
mehrfach gesagt und wir investieren
damit ganz konkret in Ihre Zukunft alle
Familien bekommen pro Kind vom ersten
Januar an 250 Euro Kindergeld und Frau
Dreher das ist die größte
Kindergelderhöhung die wir gehabt haben
in Deutschland und das übrigens auch
eine die über der Inflation und das wäre
so nicht nötig gewesen und sie haben es
nie so gemacht wie wir es jetzt machen
das ist einzigartig
wir haben den Kinderfreibetrag und wir
haben den Mindestunterhalt angehoben
Familien mit kleinem Einkommen
unterstützen wir zusätzlich zu den 250
Euro pro Kind Kindergeld mit einem
Kinderzuschlag von ebenfalls noch einmal
bis zu 250 Euro pro Kind und mit dem
Bürgergeld sollen ab 2023 auch die
Regelsätze der Kinder steigen und das
heißt ganz konkret ich habe gehört wir
haben heute waren gute Gespräche aber es
ist wichtig dass sie ihre Verabredung
auch tatsächlich ein Jahr halt einhalten
nämlich wenn sie das nicht tun dann
haben Sie ganz konkret die Verantwortung
dafür dass zum Beispiel ein Drittel der
Alleinerziehenden auf mehr Geld warten
müssen dass ihre Situation zusätzlich
verschärft und das können sie nicht
wirklich wollen in dieser Situation in
diesem Land
diese monatlichen Leistung helfen den
Familien jetzt unser Ziel aber ist die
Kindergrundsicherung denn sie ist die
Investition in die Chancengerechtigkeit
für alle Kinder und dann kann sie eben
auch mit Ihrer Unterstützung auch
hoffentlich mit ihrer Frau Bria ab 2025
ihre volle Wirkung entfalten
Liebe zuhörende dieses Land lässt sich
nicht spalten im Gegenteil wie entlasten
die Menschen schnell und verbessern aber
eben auch die Strukturen langfristig zu
unserer wohl wir verbessern auch die
Bildungschancen der Kinder und ja lange
habe ich für eine Übergangslösung für
die sprachkitas gekämpft und daran
gearbeitet aber nun ist es so wie
finanzieren die Infrastruktur für das
Programm lustige Eltern der
spracherzieherinnen von Januar an für
ein weiteres halbes Jahr aus dem Mittel
meines Hauses damit wir eben einen guten
Übergang des Modellprogramms schaffen
endlich in die Regelfinanzierung der
Länder und so die wichtige
Sprachförderung eben dauerhaft sichern
können meine Damen und Herren und
etliche Bundesländer haben bereits
gesagt dass sie es tun ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich wir haben sehr
konstruktive Gespräche es wäre super
wenn die anderen Länder auch noch folgen
dann haben wir ein ganz Deutschland
vernünftige Sprachförderung
und die 6.700 Sprachen geht das in
Deutschland haben damit endlich eine
finanzielle Klarheit damit alle Kinder
bessere Bildungschancen haben egal woher
sie kommen oder was ihre Eltern sind und
deswegen haben wir eben auch das
kita-qualitätsgesetz auf den Weg
gebracht für mehrsprachliche Bildung
mehr Gesundheit und Bewegung einen
besserer Betreuungsschlüssel und mehr
Personal in Kitas und in der Tagespflege
stellen wir in 23 und 24/4 Milliarden
Euro zur Verfügung und gleichfalls
langfristig wirkt das Elterngeld mit
knapp 8,3 Milliarden Euro ist es
übrigens der größte Posten in meinem
Etat wenn Eltern Familien und Beruf
besser vereinbaren können dann
profitieren davon auch die Wirtschaft
und auch der Arbeitsmarkt
liebe Kolleginnen mehr denn je entlastet
der Einzelplan 17 die Menschen in
schwierigen Zeiten jeder Euro
unterstützt den sozialen Zusammenhalt
denn wir lassen uns nicht spalten und
deswegen bitte ich Sie um Zustimmung zu
diesem
die
Bundesfamilienministerin hat hier ihren
Etat verteidigt unter anderem natürlich
auch ihre Entscheidung das
Förderprogramm sprachkita ist ein halbes
Jahr zu verlängern weiter zu finanzieren
da gab es hier eine Debatte ja schon
viel Kritik dass dies zu kurz sei für
eine Umstellung Thomas ehrhorn spricht
nun für die afd-fraktion herr Präsident
meine Damen und Herren in fast allen
Nationen dieser Welt herrscht ein
Konsens darüber dass die Erhaltung des
eigenen Volkes der eigenen Kultur
oberstes Staatsziel zu sein hat wer nun
die demografische Entwicklung der
Bundesrepublik betrachtet er kennt sehr
schnell dass wir hier eher von einer
demografischen Katastrophe sprechen
müssen bei einer Geburtenrate von
durchschnittlich 1,3 oder 1,4 Kindern
pro Frau
hören Sie lieber mal zu sie können was
lernen er kennt jeder sehr schnell
dass jede Generation
jede kommende Generation zahlmäßig um
ein drittelschwächer ist als die
Generation der Eltern das Eis die der
Satz von Thilo Sarrazin deutschland
schafft sich ab ist nach wie vor ohne
wenn und aber richtig dies ist natürlich
die Ursache für diverse Probleme von
Renten und ähnlichen Problemen die auf
uns zukommen das brauche ich hier nicht
zu erwähnen diese existenzbedrohende
Probleme werden aber von unserer
Bundesregierung weder erkannt noch
thematisiert und sie bilden sich schon
gar nicht in angemessener Weise im
Einzelplan 17 des familienhaushalts ab
wir auch man ist ja mit wichtigeren
beschäftigt nicht die Interessen von 97
Prozent der Mehrheitsgesellschaft
spielen eine tragende Rolle im
politischen Diskurs sondern die
Interessen und Bedürfnisse ein Jahr
Minderheiten und man fragt sich mit
welchem Recht eigentlich
gleichzeitig ist das Bestreben nach
politischer Dekonstruktion der
traditionellen Familie
Bestandteil links grüner Politik
Regenbogenfamilie und beliebige
Verantwortungsgemeinschaften sollen
künftig das ersetzen was sowohl
statistisch als auch kulturell der
Normalfall ist nämlich die Familie
bestehend aus Vater Mutter und Kindern
das was die Väter unseres Grundgesetzes
mit gutem Recht unter besonderen Schutz
gestellt haben ihre
Gesetzesinitiativen dagegen lesen sich
wie ein entwurzungsprogramm kommender
Generationen insgesamt stellen sie einen
Versuch da
final sich von allen biologischen
Tatsachen zu Bestimmung von Geschlecht
und Elternschaft zu verabschieden es ist
ein der durchschaubare versucht
lesbische Schwule und transsexuelle
Menschen für ihren politischen
Klassenkampf zu missbrauchen
ein bisschen gender Gaga noch dabei der
Versuch unsere Kinder möglichst
unabhängig von elterlicher Einmischung
frühstmöglich in staatliche Obhut zu
verbringen um wie es der Kanzler mal
ausgedrückt hat die die Lufthoheit über
den Kinderbetten zu erreichen dann noch
ein bisschen staatliche Finanzierung
linker bis linksextremer Gruppen und
über das Programm Demokratie leben das
darf selbstverständlich auch nicht
fehlen insgesamt kann man also sagen
Familienpolitik der Ampel ein toxisches
Konglomerat aus krankem überflüssigem
und schädlichen Verarmung für die alten
Entwurzelung und tiefe Verunsicherung
unserer Kinder und Jugendlichen und
welche Folgen das hat zeigt unter
anderem ein Video vom Christopher Street
Day dem tunnelplatz der
lsb-q-gemeinde in Wuppertal hier hat die
Realität die Satire längst überholt
unter anderem zeig das Video Feder ich
bin eigentlich 17 Jahre alt sagt sie
aber ich bin auch nebenbei ein Fuchs und
in dem bin ich vier Monate alt danach
stellt sich soll vor und ihre Pronomen
sind sehr und schief erklärt sie Milow
13 Jahre alt stellt sich vor sie geht
mit allen Pronomen
Daniels eine Maske mit Hundeohren
verhüllt sein Gesicht ich bin das Alpha
von einem Rudel und bin anderthalb Jahre
Papi
hier eine andere gibt an Trans zu sein
und beschwert sich das Ganze
transitioning in Deutschland das geht ja
gar nicht wirklich das wichtige sei das
Wichtigste sei es man müsse endlich den
Pronomen oder ein Pronomen für nonvenäre
Personen finden die sich keinem
Geschlecht zuordnen möchten das ist gut
dass wir ja keine anderen Probleme in
diesem Land haben schließlich kommt
weder noch einmal zu Wort und bemerkt
dass sie oft nicht akzeptiert wird weil
sie ja ein Fuchs ist manche von ihnen
werden jetzt an dieser Stelle sagen
dass jemand der sich für Napoleon oder
ein Fuchs hält vielleicht besser in
einer geschlossenen Anstalt aufgehoben
wäre eins ist aber klar was hier vor
unseren Augen passiert das ist gewollt
das ist die bewusste Zerstörung aller
gesellschaftlichen Normen und
Wertvorstellungen erzielt auf die
Diktatur von Minderheiten ab und dient
dem sozialistischen Plan der großen
Transformation zu mehr Toleranz hat es
jedenfalls nicht geführt sondern eher zu
der Frage ob wir es hier nicht mit einer
Subkultur der Geisteskranken zu tun
haben vielen Dank
thomas ehrhorn war das für die
afd-fraktion das Kabinett hat
tatsächlich ein Aktionsplan zum Schutz
Menschen beschlossen
unsere Auffassung nach gibt es darin
allerdings keine Aussagen zu Pronomen
die finden wir auch in den Einzelplänen
hier nicht unbedingt wieder Leni
breimeier kann das aber eventuell gerade
rücken falls mir hier was entgangen ist
Sprecherin für Familie Senioren Frauen
und Jugend der SPD-Fraktion
Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
liebe Frau Ministerin es ist immer
bitter hinter der AFD reden zu müssen
aber ich will Ihnen mal sagen ich bin
sehr froh sehr froh drüber dass die AFD
nicht bestimmen kann was in diesem Land
normal ist und
ich sage mal
mein Sta
at das in diesem Land alle Leute gut und
diskriminierungsfrei leben können das
ist der Staatsziel und sie haben kein
Wort zu dem Haushalt gesagt den wir
diese Woche beraten wir beraten den
Bundeshaushalt in wirklich sehr sehr
herausfordernden Zeiten wer hätte vor
einem Jahr gedacht Kolleginnen und
Kollegen jetzt hunderte von Milliarden
zum Schutz der Menschen der Familie in
der Unternehmen der Einrichtungen in die
Hand nehmen zu müssen und das wo uns
alle die Pandemie schon mehr als fordert
und gefordert hat darum lassen sie mich
zuerst unseren Haushälterinnen und
Haushältern danken die nicht alle unsere
Wünsche umsetzen konnten aber der beste
ist getan haben und am Ende dann doch
noch ein maßgeblichen Stellschrauben
drehen konnten für unsere Arbeitsgruppe
einen dicken Dank an Elisabeth Kaiser
für gute Verhandlungen und eine
transparen Kommunikation herzlichen Dank
Elisabeth unser Einzelplan
70 Haushalt für das Ministerium Familie
Seniorinnen und Senioren Frauen und
Jugend und während alle Leistungen für
diesen Personenkreis in diesem
Einzelplan 17 abgebildet dann wäre Lisa
Haushalt der größte alleine das was auf
die bestehenden Ansprüche draufkommt
lässt sich sehen die Erhöhung des
Kindergeldes es wurde gesagt ist die
größte die wir je hatten 250 Euro pro
Kind das spürt man in den Familien die
Erhöhung des Wohngeldes und die
Ausweitung des empfängerkreises das
hilft im Alltag die Ausweitung des Bafög
und seine Erhöhung das war so überfällig
und das merken Studierende und ihre
Familien bei der Erhöhung des
Mindestlohns profitieren zwei Drittel
Frauen des 49 Euro Ticket schafft mehr
Mobilität die Rentenerhöhung kann sich
sehen lassen mit der Hilfe bei den
Heizkosten unterstützen wir diejenigen
die
an seiner der schwersten Krisen seit
Bestehen der Bundesrepublik dringend
Hilfe brauchen und so weiter und so
weiter was wir in den vergangenen
Monaten Kolleginnen und Kollegen über
die Rampe geschoben haben und das was
wir in der nächsten Woche vor uns
beschließen werden das kommt bei den
Kindern den Familien den Jugendlichen
und den Seniorinnen an die am
pel hatte ich im Blick wir lassen die
Leute wir lassen die alleinerziehend mit
den gestiegenen Preisen nicht alleine
und gehen weitere wichtige Schritte in
Richtung eine armutsfesten
Kindergrundsicherung und dann geht's
natürlich auch darum was wir
gesellschaftspolitisch wollen wo wir
hinschauen sei es in Europa sein ist in
der Welt werden Frauenrechte geschliffen
sitzen sich mutige Frauen und Männer zur
Wehr gegen schlimme Regime wir hier in
Deutschland spielen aber nicht aufhalten
und freuen uns nicht an dem was ist wir
wollen mehr wir wollen echte
gleichberechtigungen setzen dafür auch
in diesem Einzelplan Zeichen mit der
Bundesstiftung Gleichstellung entfaltet
sich gerade in diesen Monaten ein
offenes Haus für Zivilgesellschaft der
deutsche Frauen hat dieses größte Frauen
und gleichstellungspolitische Interessen
die Interessenvertretung wird künftig
drei Stellen mehr haben das ist gut in
diesem
bestimmten Dachverband der
Frauenverbände wird professionell
gearbeitet und das soll auch weiter so
sein
das Deutsche Institut für Menschenrechte
hatten und unabhängige
berichterstattungsstellen zu
geschlechtsspezifischer Gewalt und zu
Menschenhandel wir werden die
istanbul-konvention mit einer
staatlichen Koordinierungsstelle
umsetzen und zudem konnten wir weitere
Akzente zum Beispiel im Bereich Hilfen
für Frauen bei Genitalverstümmelung
setzen es ist alles
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
alles enger genäht in diesem Jahr so eng
war es die letzten Jahre nicht und
deshalb können wir auf diese Akzente und
auf diesen Haushalt miteinander auch
stolz sein kümmern wir uns jetzt um die
Menschen kümmern wir uns um eine gute
gleichberechtigte Zukunft Kästner hat so
schön gesagt es gibt nichts Gutes außer
man tut es herzlichen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
Leni breimeier aus der SPD-Fraktion
verteidigt hier diesen
Einzelplan der auch wenn alles enger
genäht sei auf sie folgt halt die
Reicheneck für die Linksfraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen Frau Ministerin Paus im
pädagogischen Bereich aus dem ich ja
komme sagt man ich bin nicht wütend ich
bin enttäuscht daher sage ich ihnen von
dem Haushalt den Sie hier vorlegen bin
ich sowas von enttäuscht
ja es gibt ein aufwuchs im Haushalt des
Familienministeriums der liegt aber vor
allem beim Elterngeld und beim
Unterhaltsvorschuss Pflichtleistung also
die der Bund sowieso zahlen muss und es
gibt der Kolleginnen die stecken nicht
so im Thema daher mal eine kurze
Einordnung für die fachfremden
Kolleginnen oder die die im Ausschuss
gepennt haben denn die Ampel hat ja
immer so die Angewohnheit dass eine zu
sagen und dann das andere zu beschließen
frühkindliche Bildung so wichtig sagen
sie tatsächlich kürzen Sie bei den Kitas
durch die Hintertür 260 Millionen für
die sprachkitas ja ein halbes Jahr
werden die jetzt noch durch das
kitaqualitätsgesetz finanziert aber in
das werden nur in etwa so viele Mittel
reingesteckt wie in das Gute Kita
gesetzt trotz Inflation also eiskalte
Kürzung
Kinder und Jugendbeteiligung so wichtig
sagen sie und kürzen 30% der Mittel im
Kinder- und jugendplan wenn sie Kinder
und Jugendliche ja mal beteiligen würden
dann könnten sie die fragen ob das Sinn
ergibt und dann würden die ihnen sagen
nö aber das scheint bei ihnen in der
Regierung nicht so richtig angekommen zu
sein oder sie wollen es einfach nicht
verstehen aber weiter gewaltschutz für
Frauen so wichtig sagen sie aber die
wenigen Mittel die in einem
Bundesprogramm für Baumaßnahmen für
Frauenhäuser oder Beratungsstellen gibt
kürzen Sie um 30 %. dabei wird damit zum
Beispiel Barrierefreiheit ermöglicht und
wir alle wissen dass Frauen mit
Behinderung zwei bis dreimal so häufig
von Gewalt betroffen sind und diese
Zugänge zwingend nötig und am Freitag
beim Internationalen Tag zur Beseitigung
von Gewalt gegen Frauen werden zum Glück
wieder alle Bilder in den sozialen
Medien Posten sie sagen das eine und
beschließen das andere ich dachte mir
ich sage Ihnen das einfach mal
vielleicht sind sie auch dann wenigstens
ein bisschen enttäuscht und hören mal
auf uns enttäuscht von den Kollegen in
die das verhandelt haben und vielleicht
stimmen Sie uns demnächst mal zu wenn
wir ein bisschen mehr Geld im Familien
sagen wollen vielen Dank
die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende und auch Sprecherin
für Kinder Jugend Frauen und
Seniorenpolitik war das Heidi Reicheneck
und nächster Redner ist Matthias
Seestern pauli der familienpolitische
Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion herr Präsident
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich habe ja
gerade sehr aufmerksam zugehört Frau
Kollegin aber die erste gute Nachricht
ist und das können Sie auch nicht
wegdiskutieren dass die Mittel für
unseren Einzelplan gegenüber der
bisherigen Finanzplanung weiter steigen
die zweite gute Nachricht ist dass wir
dies schaffen und parallel die
Schuldenbremse des Grundgesetzes endlich
wieder Einheiten wir als Koalition
verfolgen mit dem vorliegenden Haushalt
das Ziel Chancengerechtigkeit und
soziale Teilhabe für alle Kinder und
Jugendlichen zu ermöglichen
parallel hierzu entlasten wir
zielgerichtet unsere Familien da sie von
den steigenden Kosten der aktuellen
Krise besonders betroffen sind und genau
deshalb haben wir die größte
Kindergelderhöhung in der Geschichte
unseres Landes auf den Weg gebracht das
Kindergeld
das Kindergeld steigt für die ersten
beiden Kinder um jeweils 31 Euro und für
das dritte Kind um 25 Euro monatlich ab
2023 an eine großartige Hilfe für die
der Bund zusätzliche zwei Milliarden zur
Verfügung stellt für eine Familie mit
zwei Kindern sind das 744 Euro und für
eine Familie mit drei Kindern sogar 1044
Euro jährlich mehr und das kann man auch
nicht weg diskutieren
außerdem erhöhen wir den Höchstbetrag
beim Kinderzuschlag für Familien mit
niedrigen Einkommen ab dem 1 Januar auf
monatlich 250 Euro meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wir alle wissen wie
schwierig die aktuellen finanziellen
Rahmenbedingungen derzeit sind und
trotzdem und trotzdem werden wir in den
nächsten beiden Jahren wieder bis zu 4
Milliarden Euro für die frühkindliche
Bildung in die Hand nehmen und in
weitere Qualitätsverbesserungen
investieren und das tun wir weil wir
faire Startchancen für alle Kinder und
Jugendlichen in Deutschland erreichen
wollen zudem ist es ist eine
verlässliche und qualitativ hochwertige
Kinderbetreuung wichtig für die
Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf
auch begrüße ich sehr dass wir uns als
Koalition für die Chancengerechtigkeit
von Kindern und Jugendlichen durch das
neue chancenpaket einsetzen dafür werden
im Haushalt zusätzlich 55 Millionen Euro
eingestellt und das ist auch richtig so
denn die Folgen der Pandemie werden sich
erst in einigen Jahren vollständig
bemerkbar machen und gerade deshalb ist
es auch so wichtig diese schon jetzt
abzumildern und niedrigschwellige
Angebote für Kinder und Jugendliche zur
Verfügung zu stellen wir lassen unsere
Kinder und Jugendlichen in Deutschland
nicht im Stich ganz im Gegenteil wir
unterstützen Sie aktiv am
gesellschaftlichen Leben teilzunehmen
und wo immer es nötig ist Hilfe in
Anspruch nehmen zu können auch wenn ich
froh dass wir im parlamentarischen
Verfahren zusätzlich die Mittel für die
Schwangerschaftskonfliktberatung die
Hilfe und Unterstützung bei ungewollter
Kinderlosigkeit und Zuweisung an die
Stiftung früher Hilfen noch mal erhöhen
konnten damit unterstützen wir Familien
in allen Lebenslagen von Beginn an
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Christian pauli
der nächste Redner ist der Kollege Dr
Hermann Joseph
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren auch in oder
gerade in aktuellen Krisen stehen wir
als Parlament insgesamt in einer ganz
besonderen Verantwortung für
nachfolgende Generationen und wie wir
diese Verantwortung wahrnehmen das zeigt
sich nicht zuletzt in der Haushaltsplan
nachhaltige Generationen gerechter
haushaltsplane Pläne sind ausgeglichen
sie verweisen darauf dass jetzt endlich
wieder die Schuldenbremse eingehalten
werde aber immerhin 45 Milliarden
Neuverschuldung haben auch sie
ausgerechnet und wir haben als
cdu/csu Fraktion einige Vorschläge
gemacht wie auch das nicht notwendig
sein müsste und sie haben das muss ja an
dieser Stelle deutlich sagen dabei nicht
erwähnt dass in 2022 noch mal eben kurz
einige Schulen auf Vorrat aufgenommen
worden sind wir haben das ein anderer
Stelle mal quantifiziert 500 Milliarden
Schulden Lasten auf den nachfolgenden
Generation
dass das gegen das Prinzip der
Jährlichkeit das ist gegen das Prinzip
der Transparenz und ist auch gegen das
Prinzip der Fairness gegenüber den
jungen Generationen die sehr deutlich
auch ihnen wird das Geschehen sagen wie
sollen wir das alles zurück bezahlen
sieht denn keiner die Zinsentwicklung
sieht denn keiner die drohende Rezession
wie ist das denn mit der langfristigen
Steuerentwicklung wie ist das mit der
Alterssicherung wie ist das mit dem
Fachkräften sollen wir das alles
bezahlen wer denkt an uns meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren diese
Haushaltspolitik ist nicht nachhaltig
sie ist nicht generationengerecht und
ist das denn die Zeiten wenn meine Damen
und Herren in der Haushaltsplanung noch
mehr Schulden
die Devise müsste lauten Schulden runter
Budgets kürzen deutlich sagen was geht
was nicht geht und eine Strategie zu
entwickeln wie wir aus diesen multiplen
Krisen herauskommen und wie wir eine
Zukunft schaffen können für unsere
Kinder wir haben Vorschläge gemacht sie
wurden nicht angenommen
nachhaltige Politik meine Damen und
Herren nachhaltig Haushaltspolitik so
könnten sie sagen ist sparsame und
gezielte Mittelverwendung verehrteren
Ministerin sie legen einen Haushaltsplan
vor der sich kaum sag ich mal gegenüber
dem vorjahresplan verändert hat die
gesetzlichen Ausgaben sind gestiegen die
programmausgaben gesunken die
Verwaltungsausgaben gestiegen und sie
sagen das ist okay so meine Damen und
Herren liebe Ministerin das ist für mich
ambitionslos und das ist eigentlich auch
ungerecht denn gerecht wäre es jetzt
Mittel zu verwenden um den jungen
Menschen in ihren Familien eine
Grundlage zu schaffen auf der sie dann
irgendwann selbst das Leben in die Hand
nehmen können und eben auch dazu
beitragen dass unser Gemeinwesen besteht
das passiert in unzureichender Weise
nicht nur im Einzelplan 17 sondern
insgesamt wir brauchen Familien die
stark gemacht werden sie wollen sie
unterstützen mit Zeit mit Infrastruktur
und auch mit Geld der Kollege gleich
darauf zu sprechen kommen was wir davon
halten wie die Infrastruktur die
Bildungs- und Betreuungsinfrastruktur
sich entwickelt oder entwickeln soll und
wir werden vielleicht irgendwann später
auch mal darüber nachdenken wie den
Elterngeld und elternzeitregelungen
aussehen müssten damit den geänderten
Anforderungen der familienrechnung
getragen wird und Kinder in diesen
Familien größere Chancen haben ich
möchte abschließend zu den finanziellen
Hilfen etwas sagen zu dem Geld das als
akute Hilfe gezahlt werden muss für
Familien und da gebe ich Ihnen recht
Frau Haus die in dieser Krise gerade in
der Inflation unter besonderen Druck
stehen und sie hatten den Aussicht
gestellt ihre Finanz- und
steuerpolitische Kompetenz an dieser
Stelle in die Waagschale zu werfen und
sich für die Familien einzusetzen und
sie verweisen auf einige Hilfsprogramme
die nötig sind auch von uns unterstützt
werden etwa wenn es um die Senkung der
faktischen Energiekosten geht um die
umsatzsteuersenkung um den
Energiepreise Deckel der demnächst
kommen soll wir wissen immer noch nicht
ob er versteuert wird oder nicht wird
das ist ein bisschen symptomatisch für
die Politik der Ampel und verunsichert
die Menschen aber immerhin passiert da
etwas zwar für alle aber auch für
Familien ich verweise auf die Kosten der
Dicke des täglichen Bedarfs da gibt es
Überlegungen die Umsatzsteuer selbst zu
für Lebensmittel für normale
Lebensmittel des täglichen Bedarfs zu
senken auch auf Hygieneartikel zu
Versorgung für den Kindern wir haben das
diskutiert verschiedentlich es gab dazu
einige Anträge die wir diskutiert haben
eine systematische Herangehensweise zu
Lösung dieser Frage sich nicht wir haben
andere Vorschläge gemacht zur Förderung
des Sparens der Vermögensbildung zu
Bildung von Rücklagen die nur im Teil
angenommen worden sind
Kinderfreibeträge sollten erhöht werden
war unsere Forderung wir haben darauf
hingewiesen dass in dringend notwendig
ist auch die das Kindergeld zu erhöhen
dem sind sie endlich in allerletzter
Minute gefolgt und der Seestern pauli
wenn Sie das als höchste Kindergeld
Erhöhung Preisen dann haben sie
vergessen dass die jeweils vierten
nichts mehr bekommen als vorher
Alleinerziehende sind kaum unterstützt
wir haben das gefordert insgesamt haben
sie Familien sicherlich einiges erreicht
da sind wir dankbar wir haben dazu
beigetragen aber viel zu viel ist noch
in der Mache der Haushalt ist insgesamt
nicht
generationengerechten sie können
nachvollziehen dass wir diesem Haushalt
insgesamt nicht zustimmen werden und im
Einzelplan 17 erst recht nicht ich danke
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
hier einige Aspekte genannt die er gern
geändert hätte die Unionsfraktion hat
auch einen Änderungsantrag hier
vorgelegt zu diesem Einzelplan über den
wenn die Abgeordneten nach dieser
Debatte abstimmen jetzt spricht aber
wahrscheinlich
die Grünen
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
unsere Demokratie ist keine
Selbstverständlichkeit diesen Satz haben
wir schon oft hier im Plenum gehört so
banal dieser Satz auch klingt er ist und
bleibt wahr für Demokratie und
Rechtsstaatlichkeit müssen wir uns
einsetzen jeden Tag
mit allem was wir haben mit unseren
Worten und Taten
weltweit stehen Demokratien unter Druck
auch direkt vor unserer europäischen
Haustür werden Demokratie und
Rechtsstaatlichkeit ungehemmt
angegriffen in Ungarn und Polen werden
Rechtsstaat und Gewaltenteilung sowie
Presse und Meinungsfreiheit an
beschnitten in Italien regiert die
rechtsextreme Georgia Meloni und auch
Schweden ist nicht gefeit gegen massiven
rechtsdruck das erfüllt mich mit großer
Sorge
doch
doch wir sind nicht zum nichts tun und
Zuschauen verdammt es gibt
unterschiedliche Anknüpfungspunkte wo
wie und womit wir unsere Demokratie
unsere Gesellschaft insgesamt stärker
und resilienter machen können deshalb
werde ich insbesondere die
gesellschaftspolitischen Maßnahmen im
Einzelplan unterstreichen diese
Maßnahmen sind nicht einfach nice to
have sie sind essentiell für eine
funktionierende und stabile Demokratie
aus diesem Grund ist die Unterstützung
zivilgesellschaftliche Arbeit im Bereich
Demokratieförderung so wichtig und
deshalb haben wir nicht nur die
Jugendmigrationsdienste selbst mit
zusätzlichen Mitteln gestärkt sondern
auch ihr Programm die Respekt Coaches
die so wichtige Präventionsarbeit an den
Schulen leisten
nur eine freie offene inklusive
Gesellschaft ist stark genug ihre
Demokratie zu verteidigen für den
Zusammenhalt unserer Gesellschaft ist es
so wichtig dass wir Vielfalt
Gleichbehandlung und Teilhabe
wertschätzen und anerkennen
als Ampel haben wir auch hier Geld in
die Hand genommen um die wichtige Arbeit
der Antidiskriminierungsstelle des
Bundes zu stärken hier haben wir nicht
nur zusätzlich Stellen geschaffen
sondern auch die Mittel insgesamt um ein
Vielfaches erhöht damit wir eine
ausstockung erreichen die sich sehen
lassen kann insgesamt sind es über 7,5
Millionen Euro
ist in den Aufbau eines bundesweiten
Netzwerkes von Beratungsstellen ein
anderer Teil ist unter anderem für
Maßnahmen die Benachteiligung
entgegenwirken sollen damit unterstützen
wir Menschen die täglich Diskriminierung
erleben zum Beispiel aufgrund ihrer
Hautfarbe ihrer Religionszugehörigkeit
und ihrer Behinderung
die Stärkung
die Stärkung der
Antidiskriminierungsstelle und die
antidiskriminierungspolitik insgesamt
haben wir uns als Ampel in den
Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben ich bin
sehr froh dass wir auch in diesen Zeiten
gesellschaftspolitische Fragen nicht aus
dem Blick verlieren vielen Dank
nächste Kollege Stefan schwarze
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen und Herren
wir beraten abschließend über den
Haushalt für das Jahr 2023 und dieser
Haushalt spiegelt unsere Anstrengung
wieder den Menschen den Familien durch
diese schwierigen Zeiten zu helfen und
gleichzeitig Impulse für die Zukunft zu
setzen
in diesen Zeit machen sich die Menschen
diejenigen die Verantwortung tragen in
Unternehmen in den Einrichtungen im
sozialgesundheitswesen und der
Behindertenhilfe viele Sorgen
wir hören Sie wir nehmen sie ernst und
wir handeln entschlossen
der möchte ich an dieser Stelle noch mal
auf die wichtigen Bestandteile unserer
entlastungspakete eingehen
alle Eltern haben im Juli einen
Kinderbonus von 100 Euro pro Kind
erhalten ab Januar 2023 wird für jedes
Kind 250 Kinder Euro Kindergeld
monatlich ausgezahlt und auch der
Kinderfreibetrag wird angeboten um
Entlastungen für die zu schaffen die es
wirklich brauchen gibt es bis zur
Einführung der Kindergrundsicherung seit
Juli 2020 einen sofort Zuschlag in Höhe
von 20 Euro pro Monat damit wurde auch
der Höchstbetrag im Kinderzuschlag auf
die 229 Euro monatlich pro Kind erhöht
das liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
sind ganz konkrete sofort spürbare
Unterstützung
und wir gehen noch weiter
um die zusätzlichen Belastungen dieser
Familien aufgrund der Inflation
abzumildern wird der Höchstbetrag des
Kinderzuschlag ab 1 Januar 2023 auf 250
Euro monatlich angerufen
alle Erwerbstätigen erhalten eine
energiepauschale von 300 Euro die seit
September 22 ausgezahlt wird das gilt
auch für alle minijobberinnen und
Minijobber unabhängig davon ob sie
steuern zahlen oder nicht und das hilft
gerade auch Alleinerziehende
im Dezember 22 bekommen auch
Rentnerinnen und Rentner ein
energiepauschale von 300 Euro und
BezieherInnen und Bezieher von Bafög und
berufsausbildungsleistungen erhalten 345
Euro
zusätzlich gibt es das neue Wohngeld
und meine Damen und Herren von der Union
sie sind herzlich eingeladen mit uns das
neue Bürgergeld zu schaffen dass sie mit
der Höhe der Regel setze des
Bürgergeldes keine Probleme haben das
haben sie ja letzte Woche schon hier im
Bundestag bewiesen jetzt lassen Sie uns
auch dafür sorgen dass wir die richtigen
Maßnahmen ergreifen dass wir die Leute
in den ersten Arbeitsmarkt reinbekommen
und das Wort des Förderns an der Stelle
auch ernst nehmen
außerdem wird der Bund im Dezember als
Soforthilfe die in diesem Monat fälligen
Abschlagszahlungen auf Gas- und
Fernwärme übernehmen das heißt die
Versorger erheben sie nicht und bekommen
das fehlende Geld vom Bund erstattet
Vermieter verrechnen die staatlichen
dezemberhilfen mit Abschlagszahlungen
der MieterInnen aber wir unterstützen
auch die Institutionen und Einrichtungen
im Bereich Familie Kinder und Jugend
deren Überleben auch durch extrem hohe
Energiepreise bedroht ist
mit der geplanten Gas- und
strompreisbremse werden alle aber auch
diese Einrichtungen stark entlastet für
Einrichtungen in der Verantwortung des
Bundes haben wir zu dem härtefallfonds
geschaffen der Fond soll die Belastung
auch aus diesem Jahr begrenzen ich kann
an dieser Stelle nur an die Bundesländer
wie Nordrhein-Westfalen appellieren
ihrer Verantwortung gerecht zu werden
und ähnliche Fonds aufzulegen und die
Einrichtungen die sie in ihrer
Verantwortung haben auch durch die Krise
zu bringen
Herr wüst es reicht nicht als
Ministerpräsident des größten
Bundeslandes immer nur nach dem Bund zu
rufen und selbst keinen Finger zu rühren
insgesamt nimmt der Bund 300 Milliarden
Euro in die Hand um die Auswirkungen der
Krise bestmöglich zu begrenzen
wir werden nicht alle Härten nehmen
können und wir werden nicht jede
Belastung ausgleichen können aber wir
stehen den Menschen den Unternehmen und
den Einrichtungen zur Seite wir tragen
mit diesem Haushalt nicht nur zur
Bewältigung der Krise bei sondern wir
setzen Impulse für die Zukunft es macht
eben einen Unterschied
für die Familien Kinder und Jugendlichen
wer die Regierung führt wir begegnen
ihnen mit Respekt und stehen Ihnen
diesen schweren Zeiten zur Seite
als Koalition werden wir die Krise
meistern und die Zukunft gestalten ich
danke Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
Stefan schwarze war das für die
SPD-Fraktion er sitzt wie auch der
nächste Redner im Familienausschuss und
das ist Nico tippelt für die
FDP-Fraktion hier im Deutschen Bundestag
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Gäste die
Familienpolitik wird vor allem durch
drei gesetzliche Leistungen geprägt dem
Elterngeld dem Kinderzuschlag und vor
allem dem Kindergeld welches wir ganz
aktuell deutlich erhöht haben deshalb
ist es richtig dass es im Bereich
Familie Senioren Frauen und Jugend vor
dem Hintergrund einer schwierigen
Haushaltslage in 2023 ein aufwuchs von
1,18 Milliarden Euro geben wird gerade
in diesem Einzelplan zeigen sich die
enorme Herausforderungen unserer
Gesellschaft die Pandemie der Krieg in
der Ukraine die gesunkene Kaufkraft eben
auch ganz konkrete soziale Problemlagen
wieder Mangel an Bewegung von Kindern
und Jugendlichen und die Einsamkeit von
Menschen
so werden die Zuwendung für das Programm
früher Hilfen auf 56 Millionen Euro
wachsen die entsprechende Stiftung
unterstützt Eltern von Kindern im Alter
bis drei Jahren in besonders belasteten
Lebenslagen mit speziellen
psychosozialen Angeboten auch für das
zukunftspaket Bewegung Kultur und
Gesundheit sind 50 Millionen Euro
bestimmt es schließt an dass bisherige
an das bisherige Corona aufholpaket und
adressiert Probleme Jugendliche wie den
Bewegungsmangel und eine exzessive
Mediennutzung nicht zuletzt findet sich
das Programm Respekt Coaches im
Einzelplan wieder welches Schülerinnen
und Schüler im Alltag begleitet
wenn wir in der resiliente Gesellschaft
wollen die Krisen meistert
Herausforderungen angeht positiv in die
Zukunft schaut dann gehören Teilhabe und
finanzielle Stabilität unbedingt dazu es
ist enorm wichtig dass wir bestimmte
Nöte bei Kindern und Jugendlichen dann
angehen wenn Sie am besten gelöst werden
können dass es genau jetzt jetzt müssen
wir die Probleme anpacken und Lösungen
liefern sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
etwa 30 Millionen Menschen engagieren
sich in Deutschland ehrenamtlich das ist
eine Zahl auf die wir in unserem Land
wirklich stolz sein können es ist
begrüßenswert dass die Deutsche Stiftung
Engagement und Ehrenamt als zentrale
Anlaufstelle mit 10 Millionen Euro für
ihre wichtige Arbeit bedacht wird die
Ampel wirkt vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
die zu reden dass der Kollege Christoph
de vriesikation
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn man sich
die Kinder und Jugendpolitik dieser
Ampel mit diesem mit diesem Haushalt
anschaut kommt dann wirklich das kalte
Grausen passiert als Koalition als
Fortschritt bezeichnen das nennen wir
Raubbau an der Zukunft der Kinder und
Jugendlichen ich habe selten eine
Regierung erlebt bei der Worte und Taten
so weit auseinander klappen wie bei
Ihnen meine Damen und Herren
denn das heute ja auch wieder lebt und
damit aber nicht genug sie haben ja noch
nicht mal die Traute zu ihren eigenen
Entscheidungen auch zu stehen und den
Bürgern reinzuschenken werfen wir doch
mal einen Blick auf den
Koalitionsvertrag was sie dort schreiben
dort heißt es wir wollen den Menschen
unabhängig von ihrer Herkunft beste
Bildungschancen bieten
Teilhabe und Aufstieg ermöglichen dazu
stärken wir die frühkindliche Bildung
Kinder verdienen beste Bildung jedes
Kind soll die gleichen Chancen haben
wenn man diese vollmundigen Worte
spiegelt an ihren Entscheidungen in den
Haushalten
2022/22 muss man feststellen diese Worte
sind wirklich der blanke Hohn meine
Damen und Herren sie kürzen die
geplanten Ausgaben gemessen an den
ursprünglichen Planungen um fast 40
Prozent von über eine Milliarde und 400
5 Millionen dieser Haushaltsplanung ist
ein Armutszeugnis für eine Koalition die
den Anspruch hat soziale Politik zu
machen und für Chancengerechtigkeit
einzustehen so wie sie das vorhin
genannt haben schauen wir uns doch das
Bundesprogramm sprach Kitas mal an dort
lautet ihr Motto gestern noch verstetigt
heute schon gestrichen man will in
Wahrheit das Programm lieber früher als
später an die Länder abgeben und für die
eigenen ideologischen Projekte
Kapazitäten zu schaffen vor einem Jahr
haben sie eine Verstetigung und
Weiterentwicklung im Koalitionsvertrag
angekündigt und nun zeigen sie dass in
Wahrheit ihnen diejenigen Kinder
besonders wenig am Herzen legen die
eigentlich unsere Unterstützung ganz
besonders brauchen meine Damen und
Herren
kann man eigentlich auf die Idee kommen
in einer Zeit wo wir jeden einzelnen
brauchen und darf niemanden verzichten
können so kurzsichtig Einsparungen auf
dem Rücken der Kinder zu beschließen wie
kann man sich im Koalitionsvertrag für
gleiche Chancen aller Kinder aussprechen
und dann als Bundesregierung vollständig
aus der frühkindlichen Sprachförderung
aussteigen sie wollen die
Kindergrundsicherung einführen und
gleichzeitig nehmen Sie billigen den
Kauf Das Kinder mit Sprachdefiziten
nicht mehr genügend frühkindliche
Sprachförderung bekommen und später auf
der Strecke bleiben meine Damen und
Herren da muss ich wirklich sagen dümmer
geht's nimmer
bei mir im Wahlkreis haben 75 Prozent
der Kinder ein Migrationshintergrund
jede zweite Kita profitiert dort von
diesem Bundesförderprogramm es war nie
sinnvoller frühzeitig in Bildung und
Entwicklung der Kinder zu investieren
und sie betreiben genau den Ausstieg aus
dieser frühkindlichen Sprachförderung
meine Damen und Herren
klar wir wollen frühkindliche
Sprachförderung nicht nach Kassenlage in
den Ländern und wir wollen keinen
Flickenteppich unterschiedlicher
landesförderprogramme wir als Union
wollen an einheitliches Programm mit
gleichen Bildungschancen für alle Kinder
und kein Stückwerk aber es ist damit ja
noch nicht genug getan sie machen mit
ihren Kürzungen an anderer Stelle weiter
kita-einstieg sei genannt oder der
Stichwort Fachkräfte offensiver im
letzten Jahr haben sie das Programm fast
vollständig eingestellt nun haben sie
das endgültige Aus besiegelt und das in
einer Zeit wo wir in Deutschland in den
Kommunen und in den Städten Händeringen
Fachkräfte suchen und prekäre
Situationen haben Eltern keine
Betreuungsplätze mehr finden dort
stellen sie die Fachkräfte Förderung ein
das ist auch ein Armutszeugnis meine
Damen und Herren
und ich komme zum Schluss mit ihrem
k-schlag versündigen sich an den
Zukunftschancen vieler Kinder in
Deutschland und auch mit wirklich gutem
Willen kann man nicht erkennen dass in
fachlich oder haushaltspolitisch
frühkindliche Förderung am Herzen liegt
und besonders bitter ist das für ein
grün geführtes Familienministerium in
dem er regelmäßig Krokodilstränen
vergossen werden wenn es um Kinderarmut
geht ich sag zum Schluss lassen Sie uns
doch besser ein frühkindliche Bildung
der Kinder kraftvoll investieren das ist
der bessere Weg aus der Armutsfalle und
das ist die größte Gewehr für ein
erfolgreiche selbstbestimmtes Leben
unserer Kinder vielen Dank
Fries war das für die Unionsfraktion und
auch er hat noch mal angesprochen das
Bundesprogramm sprach Kitas ja hier sehr
umstritten in dieser Debatte in der
Debatte rund um den etat-familie
Senioren Frauen und Jugend Nina Stahl
hören wir jetzt für die Grünen
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Zuhörerinnen man sollte ja eigentlich
die AFD einfach ignorieren aber was sie
hier Ahorn hier gemacht haben wie sie
trans-menschen und queere Menschen
verunglimpft haben das ist der würde
dieses Hauses hier wirklich nicht würdig
und das hat mächtig ist einmal ganz klar
sagen wir als Ampel und ich gehe fest
davon aus alle demokratischen Fraktionen
in diesem Haus wir stehen an der Seite
der vielen Community und ihr Hass wird
das nicht ändern
zurück zum Haushalt ein paar Punkte zur
bisherigen Debatte Liebe CDU ist stimmt
ja einfach nicht egal wie oft sie das
wiederholen dass wir die sprachkitas
beenden wollen im Gegenteil sie werden
überführt ich erzähle das gerne noch mal
in die Regel Finanzierung der Länder
denn die Länder sind zuständig es muss
endlich Schluss sein mit dem Schuld hin
und her geschiebe zwischen Bund und
Ländern alle Beteiligten müssen hier
ihre Aufgaben wahrnehmen damit alle
Kinder gute Chancen bekommen und alle
Fachkräfte gute Arbeitsbedingungen haben
der Bund leistet seinen Beitrag ist es
gut dass wir 109 Millionen aus dem
Einzelplan 60 jetzt noch mal umschichten
in den Einzelplan 17 und so den Übergang
bis zur Mitte des kommenden Jahres
ermöglichen und den Ländern eben
ausreichend Zeit geben die
Regelfinanzierung zu abzusichern Länder
Länder wie NRW Niedersachsen
Baden-Württemberg Schleswig
Schleswig-Holstein übrigens alles grün
mitregierte Länder falls Sie sich noch
mal fragen wo unser Schwerpunkt liegt
zeigen wie es geht und dass die und das
die sie werden die sprachkitas
weiterführen und er lernt wieder sie
haben gesagt die Leute wissen nicht wie
es ab Mitte des nächsten Jahres
weitergeht ja und deshalb was ist denn
mit Bayern ich kann nur an Bayern und
alle anderen Länder appellieren schaffen
sie Klarheit geben Sie den Menschen eine
klare Perspektive führen sie in den
Ländern die Sprache die das weiter
und auch damit komme ich noch mal zum
kita-qualitätsgesetz im
kita-qualitätsgesetz setzen wir
Priorität auf die Sprachförderung die
Länder können die knapp vier Milliarden
Euro die sie vom Bund in den nächsten
zwei Jahren erhalten in die
Sprachförderung investieren das ist
übrigens Geld Liebe CDU dass sie in der
mittelfristigen Finanzplanung genau wie
die sprachkitas überhaupt nicht drin
hatten und mit dem wir lieber Frau Krähe
weil sie es angesprochen haben auch die
Kindertagespflege unterstützen werden
bis kurz noch zwei Punkte zur
Unterstützung von Familien im
vorliegenden Haushaltsentwurf das ist
auch schon angesprochen die wichtige
Arbeit der Bundesstiftung früher Hilfen
stärken wir mit zusätzlichen 5 Millionen
Euro hier investieren wir in die
Prävention das ist genau der richtige
Schwerpunkt denn wir wollen nicht
hinterher an Symptomen um drinnen
sondern direkt Kinder von Anfang an gut
aufwachsen lassen
und als letztes alle Familien bekommen
die Kindergeld Erhöhung das ist auch oft
genug gesagt wir reagieren damit genau
wie mit vielen anderen Maßnahmen Kinder
sofort zuschlagung des Kinderzuschlags
Kinderbonus energiepauschale Ausweitung
der Berechtigung zum BAföG und
Wohngeldbezug um nur einige zu nennen
auf die gestiegenen Belastung durch
Inflation Energiekrise und
corona-pandemie wir machen damit die
nächsten wichtigen Schritt Richtung
Gründer Grundsicherung stehen als Ampel
verlässlich an der Seite der Familien
wir lassen die Familien nicht allein wir
helfen Ihnen durch die Krise und
schaffen so Chancengerechtigkeit
herzlichen Dank
ja das Kindergeld und der Kinderzuschlag
das bildet sich natürlich auch in diesem
Einzelplan ab 2,2 Milliarden Euro sind
dafür 2023 vorgesehen das Kindergeld
soll ja zum ersten Januar dann steigen
auf jeweils 250 € pro Monat
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Willy Brandt hat das Wesen der
Demokratie als Kompromiss beschrieben
ohne Kompromisse geht es auch hier nicht
jede Fraktion und jede und jeder von uns
streitet mit allen Mitteln darum dass
ihre politischen Wünsche Interessen und
Ideen Gehör finden und mit den
entsprechenden Geldern hinterlegt werden
denn nur so können diese Ideen in den
meisten Fällen umgesetzt werden das ist
ein sehr und anstrengender Prozess bei
dem man nie all das erreicht was man
sich gewünscht hat aber eben im
Endeffekt das was aus der eigenen Sicht
absolut nötig ist genauso nehme ich den
Haushalt 2023 war viele von meinen
Vorrednerinnen und Vorrednern aus der
Opposition erläutern heute warum sie den
Haushalt im Bereich Familie Senioren
Frauen und Jugend für einen schlechten
Kompromiss halten den muss ich
entschieden widersprechen
ich möchte erläutern was aus meiner
Sicht an diesem Kompromiss sehr gelungen
ist und warum gerade unsere
Parlamentarier der SPD und der anderen
ampelfraktion wesentlich dazu
beigetragen haben
beispielhaft will ich hierzu einige
Titel aus dem Bereich der Kinder und
Jugendpolitik des Einzelplans 17
aufführen die dank des Einsatzes unserer
Haushälterinnen und Haushälter mit den
entsprechenden Mitteln hinterlegt werden
konnten dies wird vor allem am
Bundesprogramm sprach Kitas deutlich das
von der ehemaligen Familienministerin
Schwesig eingeführte Bundesprogramm
fördert seit 2016 deutschlandweit
Kindertageseinrichtungen und Träger und
erhöht die Qualität der Integration
Inklusion und Spracherziehung von
Kindern das Programm trägt ebenso
wesentlich zur Qualifizierung der
Fachkräfte in den Kitas bei uns und bei
und ist in der Gesamtbetrachtung ein
sehr erfolgreiches kitaprogramm des
Bundes dieses Programm ist seit Monaten
medial präsent weil es aufgrund der
aktuell sehr angespannten Haushaltslage
auf Bundesebene ursprünglich zum
Jahresende auslaufen sollte ein
Missstand den wir familienpolitikerinnen
und Politiker der ampelfraktion so
gerade in der aktuellen Situation nicht
akzeptieren konnten und wollten in einer
gemeinsamen Kraftanstrengung wurde von
unseren Parlamentariern nun ein
Kompromiss verhandelt der es den Ländern
ermöglicht dieses erfolgreiche Programm
ab Juli 2023 in die eigenen
landesstruktionen zu überführen dort wo
es nach der kulturhochheit der
Bundesländer ohnehin verstetigt werden
sollte bis dahin bauen wir den Ländern
eine Brücke von 109 Millionen Euro die
das eigentlich Ende 2022 auslaufende
Bundesprogramm bis Mitte nächsten Jahres
aus Geldern des Bundeshaushalts weiter
finanziert
darüber hinaus konnten wir für die
Arbeit der Jugend migrationsdienste die
seit vielen Jahren erfolgreich junge
Menschen mit Migrationsgeschichte durch
Beratung Bildungs- und Freizeitangebote
am Übergang von der Schule bis ins
Berufsleben begleiten bereits Mitte
Oktober im Haushaltsausschuss eine
Stärkung um 8 Millionen Euro gegenüber
dem
regierungsentrufentwurf beschließen das
ist gerade in Zeiten von Flucht und
Vertreibung durch Krieg und Klima ein
absolut notwendiger Schritt
zudem konnten von unseren
Parlamentariern gegenüber dem
Regierungsentwurf für ein neues
Modellprogramm mit dem Namen mental
health Coaches 10 Millionen Euro
erstritten werden die Coaches sollen an
Schulen den Kindern und Jugendlichen als
Ansprechpartnerinnen und Ansprechpartner
dienen um so die Folgen der
corona-pandemie die für viele Kinder und
Jugendliche massive psychische
Belastungen mit sich gebracht hat
entgegenzuwirken und so Kinder und
Jugendliche aber auch deren Eltern sowie
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer in dieser
Situation nicht alleine zu lassen
besonders freue ich mich auch darüber
dass unsere Haushälterinnen und
Haushälter die Mittel der Jugend
Verbandsarbeit im Kinder- und jugendplan
in den parlamentarischen Beratungen
erneut um zusätzliche 3 Millionen Euro
gegenüber dem Regierungsentwurf stärken
konnten das hilft vor allem der Arbeit
des deutschen bundesjugendrings und
seiner Mitgliedsverbände mit diesen
Mitteln stärken wir also das politische
und soziale Engagement von Kindern und
Jugendlichen
denn der deutsche Bundesjugend drin
steht für eine Jugendpolitik die junge
Menschen wahrnimmt und ihnen
tatsächliche Beteiligung ermöglicht
darüber hinaus erhält auch die Deutsche
Sportjugend eine Aufstockung von einer
Million Euro für 2023
insgesamt konnten wir den Kinder- und
jugendplan das zentrale Förderinstrument
des Bundes in der Kinder- und
Jugendhilfe durch die parlamentarischen
Beratungen um
14,78 Millionen Euro gegenüber dem
Haushaltsentwurf der Bundesregierung
erhöhen ein großer Erfolg
dies sind nur einige Punkte weshalb ich
den vorliegenden Bundeshaushalt für den
Bereich Familie Senioren Frauen und
Jugend für einen sehr gelungenen
Kompromiss hatte vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau er sagt Anke Henning
hier für die SPD-Fraktion und dieser
einzelplane wird ja hier in zweiter
Lesung beraten und
bevor dann abgestimmt wird haben wir
noch zwei Rednerinnen Dorothee Bär jetzt
für die Unionsfraktion
Enttäuschung
was Haushalt für die Familien in unserem
Land für die Senioren für die Frauen
aber vor allem für die Kinder und für
die Jugendlichen
und Frau Ministerin sie haben ja ohnehin
im Einzelplan 17 den größten Anteil für
fixe gesetzliche Leistungen und da fragt
man sich schon was dann beim Rest
überhaupt noch da ist bei ihrer
Eigenleistung dieser Ampel da es leider
nichts da wir haben sie einen
Ausführungen der Vorrednerinnen und
Vorredner gehört dass man sicherlich
über Prioritäten auch diskutieren kann
aber die Schwerpunktsetzung die sie hier
vorgenommen haben ist absolut
unverständlich und so wie es meine
Kollegen ausgeführt haben muss jetzt
leider auch noch mal betonen
Ankündigungen und Handeln gehen völlig
diametral auseinander und das ist
wahnsinnig schade dass sie es auf dem
Rücken der Schwächsten austragen
und man fragt sich ja schon und es tun
ja viele in dem Land auch wenn sie es
vielleicht nicht für möglich gehalten
haben Menschen lesen Koalitionsverträge
damit haben Sie wahrscheinlich nicht
gerechnet und ihr Koalitionsvertrag ist
reine Makulatur wenn sie da noch
ankündigen dass sie die sprachkitas
nicht nur fortführen wollen sondern
verstetigen wollen und jetzt die ganzen
sprachkitas rasieren wollen an die Wand
fahren ohne Not und jetzt schreien war
nicht so gedacht wir hatten das da
reingeschrieben ist es in der Nacht von
Nebelaktion früher um drei von irgendein
Praktikanten noch reingeschrieben worden
sie wussten es nicht und jetzt schieben
Sie es auf die Länder und ich finde es
perfide diese schwarze Peter Spiel
wirklich perfide sicher hinzustellen und
zu sagen bloß soll die Länder machen wir
haben zwar versprochen aber jetzt sonst
die Länder machen an dieser Stelle ich
finde es total beeindruckend Frau Star
ausgerechnet sie als jemand der aus
Berlin kommt sich jetzt an anderen
Landesregierungen aber rein zu wollen da
braucht man schon viel das muss man mal
wirklich sagen
also wirklich das finde ich ja und
selbst wenn es Berlin machen würde woher
bekommt in Berlin das Geld aus dem
Länder Finanzausgleich aus Bayern das
könnten nämlich auch zur Wahrheit dazu
an dieser Stelle ja ich weiß dass sie
immer
von mir auch leid dass es bei uns alles
so gut läuft
aber Sie können sich an der Scheibe
davon abschneiden also wie gesagt
angekündigt nicht weitergeführt nach 8
Monaten Katze aus dem Sack knallhartes
förderhaus mit kurzer Verlängerung warum
Union sei Dank wir haben in unseren
Wahlkreisen überall kita-gipfel
durchgeführt und haben da wirklich mal
das Land aufgemischt und dann ist auch
die Ministerin aufgewacht und hat mal
festgestellt dass es vielleicht doch
nicht so opportun ist auf dem Rücken der
Erzieherinnen das ganze auszutragen in
unserem Land und genau deswegen genau
deswegen
eine Verlängerung weil der Aufschrei der
Fachwelt so gigantisch war erlauben sie
eine Zwischenfrage des Kollegen Höhle
ich habe gar nicht gewusst dass man in
Bayern keine Luft holen muss wenn man
redet also kommen wir aus Franken da
geht es noch besser nee der hat ja schon
Redezeit gehabt der Kollege und die Rede
fahren jetzt gar nicht prickelnd also
wer die Frage auch nicht so prägend sein
soll also im selben unrechtlichen Stil
und auch das gehört zur weiter zu ich
bin meiner Kollegin Silvia dankbar das
ist angesprochen hat weil von der Ampel
macht's nämlich niemand im selben
unredlichen still stampfen sie auch das
Bundesprogramm pro Kindertagespflege ein
so die unions regierte Bundesregierung
hat noch im letzten Jahr bei der
mittelfristigen Finanzplanung für eine
Weiterführung Sorge getragen und das
sind sie wieder die 16 Jahre die sonst
dauern vorhalten 16 gute Jahre in der
Familienpolitik die Sie in weniger als
16 Monaten völlig an die Wand fahren
Gefahren erfolgreiche
strukturenfrage aus der SPD-Fraktion
aber es verlängert ihre Redezeit also
wenn Sie die Frage alles gut ich mache
ich will ich erlaube es jetzt deswegen
nicht weil ich jetzt nämlich mal mit
etwas aufklären muss was wirklich auch
mal die Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer
bestimmt interessiert weil wenn ich sie
mir so anschau stelle ich fest dass sie
alle friedliche Steuerzahlerinnen und
Steuerzahler sind hören Sie mal zu in
diesem Jahr werden Schulden gemacht
in einem Jahr wie Bund Länder Kommunen
und Sozialversicherungen zusammen in 40
Jahren und das ist das wo die FDP sich
hinstellt und sagt sie versuchen da noch
redliche Haushalte zu machen das machen
sie nämlich nicht nur zur Einordnung der
Dimension der vermeintlich
generationengerechten und nachhaltigen
Haushaltsführung dieser Ampel und bei
den Familien kommt dabei überhaupt
nichts an und das ist das Schlimme das
heißt die sprachkitas die
Kindertagespflege weitere erfolgreiche
Programme aus den letzten 16 Jahren
verstecken sich in den Maßnahmen zur
Umsetzung der Qualifizierungsoffensive
es wird alles umgeschichtet es kommt
nicht bei Kindern an es kommt nicht bei
Jugendlichen an und das schlimme ist die
Menschen spüren dass sie sich auf ihre
Politik nicht verlassen können gerade in
diesen herausfordernden Zeiten wird
gespürt und das schlimme ist am meisten
würde man sich ja auch als Familie auf
eine Bundesfamilienministerin verlassen
mögen und ich warte einfach dass sie
sich mit ein bisschen mehr Elan ein
bisschen mehr Leidenschaft auch um
diejenigen kümmern die Ihnen hier
anvertraut sind politisch ihnen wird in
Zukunft keiner mehr ernsthaft glauben
dass ihnen an der Qualität der
Kinderbetreuung irgendwas am Herzen
liegt sie brauchen das hier von diesem
Pult nicht mehr machen stimmen Sie
unseren Anträgen zu dann können sie noch
was retten aber so wird es nächste
leider leider
sagt Dorothee Bär hier für die
cdu/csu-fraktion die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende die sich da warm
geredet hatte und dann auch keine
Zwischenfragen mehr zugelassen hat
dieser Wert darauf gelegt haben dass wir
uns Franken kommen und nicht so die
Fraktionen hat eine kurze Navigation
beantragt die zulasse das Wort hat der
Kollege das jetzt statt Zwischenfrage
prozenttervention liebe Frau Bär das war
ja wirklich ein abenteuerlicher Ritt
jetzt in ihrer Rede hier durch den
Haushalt mit dem sie sich offensichtlich
nicht wirklich intensiv beschäftigt
haben ich kann jetzt nicht in dieser
Kurzintervention mit all diesen falschen
Unterstellungen auch haushaltspolitisch
aufräumen deswegen will ich ihn einfach
zwei Fragen stellen die ich sonst gerne
noch in der Zwischenfrage gestellt hatte
die erste ist sie haben ja jetzt hier
mehrere Male dargestellt was Bayern
alles leistet für Deutschland
wir haben hingegen dargestellt dass
viele Länder jetzt die Weiterführung der
sprach Kitas im Kita qualitätsgesetz
entsprechend wahrnehmen eigene
sprachförderungsprogramme auf den Weg
bringen und meine konkrete erste Frage
an Sie ist wann können wir denn mit dem
sprachförder Diagramm von Markus Söder
in Bayern rechnen das ist die erste
Frage die zweite Frage ist
die zweite Frage ist da hat meine
Kollegin Nina Star dankenswerterweise
darauf hingewiesen nämlich das in ihrer
Finanzplanung die sie in ihrer Regierung
aufgestellt haben die sprach Kitas ja
gar nicht etatisiert waren die waren ja
gar nicht drin und daher meine ganz
konkrete Frage vor dem Hintergrund ihrer
Äußerungen hier die ja komplett
gegensätzlich sind warum eigentlich
nicht
[Applaus]
um ihre zweite Frage zuerst zu
beantworten wir haben es immer weiter
geführt und es war auch nach den vielen
vielen Jahren auch bei den Erzieherinnen
vor Ort und ich war in vielen
Kindertagesstätten in den letzten Wochen
und Monaten auch kommen Sense das klar
war dass es auch weiter finanziert
werden würde und selbstverständlich
hätten wir das auch weiter finanziert da
bin ich 1000% nicht sicher Punkt eins
und Punkt 2
es ist so es ist so es hat sich in den
letzten Jahren bewährt es ist von der
Fachwelt als ein als das erfolgreichste
Programm überhaupt abgefeiert worden und
deswegen der selbstverständlich
weitergegangen weil wir erfolgreiche
Programme nicht ohne Not an die Wand
fahren und zum Punkt ist
ehrlicherweise hat Frau Paust großartig
angekündigt dass sie sich mal mit allen
Ländern ins Benehmen setzen will und
ehrlicherweise erwarte ich von einer
Bundesministerin auch insofern
führungsstarke das ist auch schafft mal
die 16 Länder an einen Tisch zu bekommen
und in unserem Land in unserem Land wird
alles
interessiert sie die Antwort Frau schaus
anscheinend nicht anscheinend nicht
die Arroganz der Macht das bei der Ampel
aber ganz schön schnell eingezogen
unser Bundesland geht immer über die
normalen Leistungen hinaus immer immer
und es werden wir jetzt mal in den
nächsten Wochen abwarten ich finde es
nur nein ich finde es nur wir werden es
doch am Schluss retten wir es doch immer
für euch das ist doch immer ist es
einfach aber ich finde es halt einfach
unredlich zu sagen FDP grüne SPD wir
fahren es an die Wand und jetzt brauchen
wir euch weil was alleine nicht schaffen
schade setzen Sechser Kollege
[Applaus]
herzlichen Dank ich bin das beide
Selbstbewusstsein wieder bemerkenswert
aber da das Positive deutsche
Bundestages ja auch Dienstleister ist
Herr Kollege die Sitzungsleitung sitzt
nicht vor seiner präsentiert die
Sitzungsleitung sitzt nicht vor seiner
präsidiert also frau Präsidentin oder
herr Präsident war so angesprochen
so letzte Redner in dieser Debatte ist
der Kollege Daniel weil die SPD-Fraktion
und das sagt Bundestags Vizepräsident
Wolfgang
[Applaus]
zurück aus Franken in die Realität sehr
geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
eine bessere Beleuchtung des
öffentlichen Raums Bezahlung von
Pflichtpraktika für SchülerInnen mehr
öffentliche Trinkbrunnen in der
Innenstadt das sind Forderungen der
Mainzer jugenddemokratiekonferenz die
dieses Jahr im September zum ersten Mal
stattfand junge Menschen erarbeiten hier
ein Katalog von Zukunftsideen für die
eigene Stadt warum erzähle ich das
veranstaltet wird die
jugenddemokratie-konferenz vom
Jugendforum Mainz das zum Haus des
Erinnerns gehört das Haus des Erinnerns
wird gefördert durch das Programm
Demokratie leben und mit der
jugenddemokratie-konferenz macht das
Jugendforum Mainz genau das Demokratie
leben seit 2014 wird das Programm
durchgeführt und im kommenden Jahr
wachsen die Ausgaben zur Stärkung von
Vielfalt Toleranz und Demokratie um 16,5
Millionen Euro das ist ein Ampel Erfolg
und das ist gut für unsere Demokratie
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Gratismentalität in der
demokratiebildung muss überdacht werden
es gab mir die Leiterin des Hauses im
September mit auf den Weg die Akteure
brauchen Planungssicherheit nicht nur
abstrakt als Organisation sondern
insbesondere für die vielen engagierten
und gut eingearbeiteten Beschäftigten
die oftmals mit befristeten Verträgen zu
kämpfen haben
ob das das Demokratie fördergesetz so
erkennen wird Demokratie Förderung und
extremismusprävention als Aufgabe des
Bundesamt und geben finanzielle
Sicherheit das ist der richtige Schritt
zur richtigen Zeit meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
2014 wurde neben Demokratie leben aber
auch die Stiftung frühe Hilfen ins Leben
gerufen seitdem stagniert der
Bundeszuschuss für die Stiftung bei 51
Millionen Euro pro Jahr die Mittel der
Stiftung frühe Hilfen werden wir
dynamisieren so steht es in unserem
Koalitionsvertrag und mit diesem
Haushalt gehen wir dazu den ersten
Schritt und erhöhen den Ansatz um 5
Millionen Euro und Frau breher weil sie
eben die Stiftung früher Hilfen
angesprochen haben nein wir verringern
den Ansatz nicht um 35 Millionen Euro
das waren die Corona Soforthilfen die
sie dazu gerechnet haben im Vergleich zu
2019 gehen wir um 5 Millionen Euro rauf
das ist nämlich die Wahrheit und damit
setzt sich
damit unterstützen wir Eltern von Beginn
der Schwangerschaft bis zum dritten
Lebensjahr des Kindes gerade in
belastenden Lebensjahren und es ist ein
ganz ganz wichtiges Zeichen um Kindern
in Deutschland eine gesunde Entwicklung
aber auch ein gewaltfreies Aufwachsen zu
ermöglichen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen denn
denn gewaltfreies Aufwachsen ist leider
immer noch keine Selbstverständlichkeit
in Deutschland und so oft schauen wir
nicht gut genug hin um häusliche Gewalt
und sexuellen Missbrauch zu verhindern
dabei wissen wir dass drei Viertel aller
Fälle sexuellen Missbrauchs bei Kindern
im privaten Umfeld passieren
Aufklärungskampagnen müssen also auch
auf diese dunkle Fälle in privaten
Umfeld aufmerksam machen um wirksam zu
sensibilisieren und genau das tun das
bildungsbundes Bundesfamilienministerium
und die unabhängige Beauftragte für
Fragen des sexuellen Kindesmissbrauchs
mit ihrer in der vergangenen Woche
vorgestellten auch vorgestellten
Aufklärungskampagne
schieb den Gedanken nicht weg lautet der
Titel
zum Beispiel den Gedanken den Kollege
Hönel hat es bereits angesprochen dass
in jedem deutschen Klassenzimmer ein bis
zwei Schülerinnen und Schüler sitzen die
bereits Opfer sexualisierte Gewalt
wurden
Sensibilisierung in allen
gesellschaftlichen Bereichen ist deshalb
der erste Schritt damit Dunkelziffern
nicht länger im Schatten bleiben und
betroffene Kinder und Jugendliche Hilfe
und Gerechtigkeit erfahren damit die
unabhängige beauftragte die Themen
aufklärung und Sensibilisierung im
kommenden Jahr stärker in die breite
Öffentlichkeit tragen kann erhöhen wir
die Mitte auf 12,2 Millionen Euro liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im Bereich der
Prävention und Aufklärung muss
Deutschland besser werden das ist auch
der Auftrag an uns als Ampelkoalition
und mit diesem Haushalt gehen wir dabei
den richtigen Weg vielen Dank
sagt Daniel Baldi für die SPD hier
letzter Redner zu diesmal zu planen
17 Bundesministerium für Familie
Senioren Frauen und Jugend in der
ausschussfassung hierzu lieber
Änderungsantrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
auf Drucksache 4539 vor wer stimmt für
diesen Änderungsantrag CDU CSU und Linke
und AFD wer stimmt dagegen
die Koalitionsfraktionen damit ist der
Änderungsantrag abgelehnt dann kommt
dieser Änderungsantrag da hat die Union
ja schon deutlich gemacht dass sie das
ablehnt wie die sprachkitas jetzt weiter
gefördert werden soll nämlich nur ein
halbes Jahr vom Bund und die Union hat
in diesem Änderungsantrag noch gefördert
dass die Zuweisung an die Stiftung
früher Hilfen erhöht werden soll aber
das hat hier keine Mehrheit gefunden